e
all right uh good morning everyone I'm
going to uh call the uh executive
session of the house Judiciary Committee
to order and I'd first ask you to rise
Allegiance Al to the flag United
States the stand
na
all so
um the first thing that I want to do is
just uh take a moment of personal
privilege if I could to thank uh my vice
chair representative Manion um and
really all uh representative Alexander
uh and all the members of the committee
for uh um carrying on while I was gone
that you did outstanding work uh got a
lot a lot of stuff done and I very much
appreciate that so thank you um
then I want to uh turning to the bills
the first uh I know that there is a
concern on the part of at least one of
the representatives uh who has other
commitments um and is particularly
concerned about uh our dealing with
certain bills that um she has a
particular interest in and I I have to
say I I also have a commitment later
this afternoon so for that reason I'm
going to turn to HB
148 um as the first bill uh to uh that
we will exact um and I'm going to repres
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass on House Bill 148 is there a
second I second that move move by
representative Pell second by
representative Alexander representative
pel would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you um House Bill 148
is relative to permitting classification
of individuals based on biological sex
under certain
circumstances and this identical bill
passed both the house and the Senate as
House Bill 396 um in
20124 House Bill 148 acknowledges New
Hampshire's fundamental commitment to
treat all persons with dis without
discrimination and with equal respect
and dignity it also acknowledges the
fact that there are certain
circumstances in which recognition of
biological sex may be necessary for the
physical safety and privacy rights of an
individual especially when but not
limited to minors the three
circumstances in which this bill permits
biological sex to be utilized as a basis
for classification are limited to
multiple use bathrooms athletic or
sporting events of a um of a Kind where
an advantage to biological males is
recognized to exist and Facilities where
an individual is committed volun
involuntarily even in these limited
situations the build does not require
classification based on biological sex
it merely allows for this to occur if
the institution in question determines
the same as necessary now during the
hearing there was some concern expressed
regarding the definition of biological
sex and until recently there was really
no problem or significant need to
routinely define specific different
characteristics of what make a person
male or
female it is now possible to perform an
atome test for gender identity on a
fetus as young as 6 to 8 weeks gestation
this is done by taking a sample of the
mother's blood and testing for the
presence of male DNA the absence of male
DNA means the unborn child is most
likely
female those tests are available at your
local drugstore like Walgreens CVS you
can also order them
online on February 19th the same date as
the hearing for House Bill 148 the US
Department of Health and Human Services
took action on the current
administration's executive order
defending women and children this
includes a definition of biological
sex failure to maintain sex-based
distinctions could now possibly put
federal education and Public Safety
funding at risk according to the
executive order defending women from
gender ideology
recent events both nationally and
locally indicate the need for this
legislation in Maine just last week a
state representative was censured and
silenced for drawing attention to
biological males participating in female
sports and their unfair
Advantage the state of Maine is speaking
out one quote that I heard as I was
paying attention the news cycle last
week was from a young girl who said that
now she doesn't have to fight this alone
well shame on us adults we shouldn't be
allowing children to fight this fight
for us for themselves I should say in
our own state two female athletes have
signed on to the lawsuit challenging our
own women in sports
law with wide swings and executive
orders between administrations House
Bill 148 is necessary and The Time Is
Now to protect our women and girls in
the granite state
anyone else wish to be heard
representative
tur yeah thank you Mr chair thanks for
take uh for allowing me to comment um I
imp opposed to this bill on on a a
number of grounds I
think I I'll open up by saying and I
don't mean this offensively it it's it's
almost legislative malpractice it seems
to me to put a bill out that not only
doesn't actually Define the key
terminology which is biological sex and
thank you for clarifying what your
Precision on it is but it's not embodied
in the bill um there are as I mentioned
during the hearing at least four four
approaches
to defining biological sex um and these
can be changed either naturally or
through uh medical intervention through
through throughout your life um guess
what i' what I'd like to say and and
hope that folks um around the table will
consider when voting on this is the
thing that this bill intends to
solve seems like it will almost be
caused by this bill and give me one
minute to explain that I won't go on too
long if we choose chromosomes and by the
way there's more than two versions of
chromosomes um alone but if we choose
that we're basically saying you know it
it's it's your identity your gender your
Birth there's there's actual history
here
where forcing someone to say join a
sports team based on their sex at Birth
causes the exact problem that I think
folks are trying to
avoid and that is say in sports hormones
determine
your musculature hormones determine your
your
physique um there's a story from from uh
Texas where uh a trans youth named Mt
begs um was forced by a bill just like
this to
play on a women's sports team for
wrestling he was a wrestler um born a
female now a male presents as a
male uh was forced to wrestle on the
girls wrestling team he became the
undefeated
undefeated uh wrestling champion of the
State of Texas for two years in a
row um against his will he did not want
to wrestle on the girls team I I just
want to put that out there this does not
and this does not even say you have to
treat the two genders that way the
school across town could choose to treat
it the opposite way there is no
definition in here about
what we're talking about for the two
genders and even if we knew what we were
talking about for the two genders how
those should be embraced different
restaurants could choose different
standards for for what bathroom and one
place you could be forced to go in one
the other place you could be forced to
go in another depending on whether it's
the way you look today or it's the way
you you looked when you were born or
some other standard I'll set aside the
privacy concerns about how anyone would
actually um adjudicate whether or not
the person in question would or wouldn't
be treated a certain way according to
this so I just hope people will pause
and say you know do you really want your
constituents calling and saying why is a
person with a beard wrestling on our um
on our girls team and the answer would
be because of this bill because this
bill allows that um it doesn't say what
way the the advantage needs to run so I
I will stop there but I I I I I I I just
want to make it really clear that that I
think this is dangerous and I think this
is this is because it lacks the
Integrity to actually Define what it's
trying to say leaves the door wide open
for for discrimination in the worst
possible alwayss thanks other people
representative organ um yes first of all
the uh I guess I reiterate without going
on too much length the chromosomes do
not necessarily determine what your
gender expression is and of course what
really counts is your gender gender
identity what you believe yourself what
you believe yourself to be and what
other people expect to be which is not
necessarily what you're assigned to to
birth and then what you're assigned to
birth doesn't necessarily match up with
the chromosomes so these chromosome
tests you can buy a Walgreens um that's
um not really that what you do in the
what you do with the with the embryo
doesn't really necessarily determine
like what the child will be U when it's
um when it's born and um so there's uh
you know there's many people who do not
fall on one side of the uh gender line
or the or the other so they should uh
they have the same rights as everyone
everyone else and also of course any
definition of biological sex is totally
absent from this bill and um you know
think I asked the prime sponsor about
and he just sort of shrugged it off say
everybody knows what it is um you know
certainly a bad definition is worse than
no definition at all and c and
um so I just I probably just think this
this bill is unnecessary and you know in
terms of the three circumstances there
you know it's already regardless of uh
regardless what your crimin romes are or
what what your gender identity
expression is you know it's illegal to
um it's it's illegal to assault or
harass someone in any public any setting
including know including the laboratory
U the prisons already of the right to uh
and the duty to put prisoners um where
they where they're the least danger to
themselves and to the other prisoners
and um and the sports the sports teams
can uh sporting competitions can and do
like determine the rules for who's
eligible eligible to participate and
there's only three cases in high school
sports here in New Hampshire and um I
think I believe all the
three trans young trans women truly are
truly are women and soly the record
doesn't show that any of them have an
unfair Advantage you know their teams
have not been any more successful more
or less successful any the other team so
that's uh I just feels well was totally
unnecessary and finally there's
reference to like Department of Health
and Human Services uh Federal at the
federal level they're I think they're
mirroring what the president executive
order was and his executive order was
very badly worded in fact the way I read
it and of course I'm not necessarily A a
uh I'm not say an expert on genetics but
the world way I read it seems like
everybody in the room is female the
including those of us like me who
present as male and believe themselves
the male um you know so apparently he he
he he put out an executive order which
apparently means that everybody in this
room including the men are are females
so that's I wouldn't go by that
definition at all so it was just this BS
just feels just unnecessary
counterproductive and uh should be uh
should be found inexpedient to legislate
so all right other anyone else wish to
Smith thank you I wonder if I could ask
a question of um the maker of the motion
um I I was fascinated
about uh the part about the test that
you could take at home um is there a
requirement for people to take that test
I I'm showing my age of course but one
of the
wonderful moments was uh when in my two
pregnant
when what emerged was a surprise to me
um the first was a a male and the second
was a female
and we had no idea until then and I
believe that there are people now who
choose not to know
um is this something that's a
requirement I mean that talk about
this would be a really fun conversation
to have in private however since we're
not in private I was stunned to find out
that this test was a possibility that
you could do it at home in fact a friend
of mine emailed me a picture of the test
during the hearing on 148 two weeks ago
and I I hadn't realized that such a
thing was possible but it's quite common
now for people to find out what the sex
of their child is going to be through an
ultrasound typically I thought until I
found out about this test um and then
they have gender reveal parties and all
kinds of things but I I miss the days I
have to say of the surprise like oh you
had a girl you have a girl oh you have a
boy those that mystery is kind of
escapes us these days thank you other
anyone else wish to comment seeing none
I think we're ready uh for a vote on the
uh
on HB 148 the motion is ought to pass
and I'd ask the clerk please to call the
role Vice chairman Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland
yes representative gzowski yes
representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative Burch no representative
Paige no representative
Manos
no Representative turer no
representative Rambo no Representative
berson
yes 10 Ys eight nay
all right so the motion carries um
representative perel may I ask you to uh
yes do the report and listen I'm just
this is going to be General um we got a
lot of work to do before the crossover
uh time so I'm going to ask everyone to
please get your reports to me by no
later than 6: pm tonight okay um I
really need to have those uh and I
assume there will be a Minority Report
yes representative tur will be right
inity
minority all right um next I'm going to
turn to um uh and take up open the
executive session on House Bill
254 and I'm going to recognize myself
for uh a motion I move ought to pass is
there a second
moved by uh representative Lynn seconded
by representative Smith um and I'm going
to um this bill has you know we we we P
the house passed this bill last year I
think everybody is kind of familiar with
it um my I'm going to just speak very
briefly in support of it I think to me
this bill is about Liberty it's about
the question of whether or not I should
have the ability um
assuming I'm I meet all the requirements
of the bill as as repres as reflected by
uh two doctors and if necessary a
psychologist or psychiatrist or whatever
if I meet all those requirements should
I have the option and I'm within six
months of death should I have the option
of being able to end my death in a
peaceful manner as opposed to suffering
uh until I die I know that there are
strong religious beliefs and other
beliefs on on the other side of the
aisle and you know I I expect everyone
will built their conscience uh to me my
conscience says that this bill should
pass and I hope that um you will agree
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
representative
Perez I feel very strongly against this
bill because not the intent of the bill
because I have one side of me that is
the religious side but I have the other
side that is the legislator side So
based on the legislator side
this is a faulty faulty bill it is an
extreme we already have in this country
that anorexics are able to get hold of
the are able to utilize this and the
state veteran advisory commission which
reports to the governor 20 veteran
services organizations voted unanimously
to oppose this bill for its second
this thank you all right anyone else
wish to be heard representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair I'm just going
to make this brief I've been around for
a long time I have seen painfully things
in my family
that some would say they should maybe
take a pill I just can't go there to me
a doctor
takes an
oath to save life and we're going to
pass a bill where a doctor can give
somebody a
pill and and so they can pass on I just
don't think it's right and I will vote
against this bill again like I did last
year thank you all right anyone else
wish to be heard yes representative pno
thank you Mr chair yes I am also
adamantly opposed to this bill um and I
won't even go into the details within
the bill
however I find the subject to be
exceptionally deceptive every time the
bill is presented it has a different
name a different
euphemism um to Cloud the issue and so
from the start I find the the bill to be
deceptive and at the end where the cause
of death is the underlying illness not
the ingestion of the medication that
actually causes the death that level of
deception um we would NE we will never
know how many people actually die this
way if we don't have the truth about how
people
die or how they end their
lives or whether or not they die
naturally I I just the certainly cannot
vote for deceptive legislation like this
anyone else wish to be heard so the last
I I guess I I do feel necessary to
respond to one of the things you said
representative uh panel because it you
know I I thought about this when during
the hearing when somebody made basically
the argument you're making and as I
thought it through I I think one of the
things that that is important to
understand is this it is true that this
bill defines someone who dies meeting
the meeting the circumstances of what
the uh which I think are pretty
stringent of what the bill requires as
not being a suicide now you might say
well that's deceptive that's a lie the
analogy I would draw is we have in
various areas of the law and I would
draw in particular the case of of
expungement of criminal records the law
says that somebody who has been
convicted of a crime can apply and if
they meet the requirements to have their
their convictions expunged then they are
no longer convicted and they can answer
questions on an employment application
and all of those things to say no I have
not been convicted now you might say
that's a lot they really have been
convicted but the law has said look the
these are in these circumstances we
think it's appropriate to allow the
person to be sort of rehabilitated I
think the same by analogy the same
situation applies here the law can say
if you are if you have a terminal
illness and you're within 6 months of
death and you don't really you know
those those people don't want to die but
what they also don't want to do is to
suffer in the last moment last hours of
or days of their death they um and they
want to be able to end their their lives
peacefully I think the law can
appropriately say that we won't we won't
classify those people as having
committed suicide so that I think that's
the answer to that question
representative uh uh
Perez we're not talking about a criminal
we're talking about someone's life kill
literally taking their life my biggest
concern is if we justify suicide at the
state level the young people who now are
between the first or second cause of
death up to the age of 34 will feel that
their
depression is a terminal
illness and feel that well the state
says it's okay to do this even though
they're not doing it through this
assisted suicide we're
justifying we're
justifying The Taking of a human life
and our
platform I'm a republican our platform
this is
totally 100% against it that's not why
I'm voting against it I'm voting against
the bill is faulty we already have other
people ingesting the medications and not
the person who it was for we have
anorexics who are young who are being
given this it the slippery slope has
started in the United
States anyone else wish to be
heard representative
tur yeah just a couple of thoughts um
let me first talk about the the uh death
certificate issue um you know as someone
who's worked with Public Health Data for
my whole life um it's important not to I
think in if if in a law like this
allow the confusion of the cause of
death which we use to understand the
changes of disease statuses in our
society with something that if this were
permitted would be exercising a legal
right that you have to prevent
suffering if we pervert this so that all
of these things were to become somehow
caused by the exercise of this what
would be legal right that you have we're
basically throwing out the ability to
study things like changes in cancer
rates and changes in um in mortality um
so I I think it's important to have a
provision like this for that reason um
the only other thing I'd like to say is
in terms of the the the underly in I
guess I'll call it
morality I think it's important to make
the
distinction with medicine and and the
the the the oath you take is to do no
harm first um
that suicide is about ending a otherwise
ongoing life um medicine knows the
difference between somebody who is
living and somebody who is terminally
dying and it's not in my mind possible
to call something suicide if the outcome
in Fairly short order is death you are
dying you're not taking your life um
maybe that's a distinction that that
others disagree with but I think it's an
important one and I just wanted to
mention it thanks anyone else wish to be
heard seeing none I guess we're ready
for the vote I the motion before us on
uh HB 254 is ought to pass and I would
no uh representative Alexander no
representative trip yes representative
Andrew
no Representative kutab no
representative Perez
no clerk votes no representative
McFarland
yes representa gzowski
no representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Burch
yes representative Paige
yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo
yes representative berson
Nays um I will write uh the majority
report um will there be a Minority
Report and who so will you write it to
okay I have a question if we only had 18
votes there's 19 people on the committee
so is it was it perhaps 11 to8 11 to 7
there's 18
I'm sorry 11 to S oh that makes sense
think you
just 11 to S all right
um my apologies I I guess I I forgotten
my fourth grade math
um then there's one uh one more bill
that that um we need to make sure we we
get done before representative Perez and
myself have to leave but we can do that
um uh early this afternoon so I then
would now return to the order listed in
the
uh uh in the notice and I would
um turn to uh HB 611
FN
and I didn't move I didn't move anything
yet no problem so so uh Mr chair yes uh
uh well hang on one second I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna first recognize
um I'm going to
recognize myself and move
uh
um otpa on uh HB 611 with Amendment 2025
that I'll second it all right so I are
you seconding it I second everyone
second it all right everyone all right
so all right so move move by myself
seconded by representative cutab um and
I will take a moment to speak to this
um the the amendment in question is a
replace all Amendment it replaces the
bill the purpose of the bill as
originally drafted would have been
essentially to say that the office of
Cost Containment needs to end efforts to
recoup um monies that uh will provide uh
funds that were expended to provide um
uh Council services and related services
for um Indigent PE uh Indigent defend
criminal defendants or juveniles who are
charged with juvenile delinquency
offenses
um my
Amendment
basically replaces the that entire bill
with a with an amendment that
essentially restores the law to what it
was prior to 20 to the 2020 amendments
to RSA uh 604
A9 um and in
particular
um it was those amendments passed when
um the our our uh friends on the other
side of the aisle were in control of the
legislature um that um basically did a
number of things one of the things is
that it made it said that if you were if
you were provided the services of if you
were Indigent provided the services of
council and you were found not guilty
the state could not um attempt to recoup
uh the funds from you um I think that is
totally totally inappropriate um because
if you or I are are charged with an
Defence and we retain our own lawyer and
we're found not guilty we don't get to
charge the state for uh the funds for
the expense we paid for our lawyer um I
think basically and and in incidentally
if you read the fiscal note to this uh
to the original bill it indicates that
there was a huge drop off in the amount
of money that the office of Cost
Containment collected after that change
in the law was made because the other
thing that that that that that the law
that that law in 2020 did is it
basically said if the if the judge
decides that the person can't afford to
pay there's no reexamination of it that
that cannot be reexamined by the office
of Cost Containment I think it's really
important that everyone understand this
point and I I you know I've signed
hundreds of those uh maybe thousands of
those appointment of counsel things and
as as every other judge did when during
the time that I was a judge it's
important to understand there is in the
judicial branch there is no I mean it
would be an extraordinary circumstance
where there was actually any checking of
whether the information contained in the
financial affidavit is accurate when
somebody files a financial affidavit and
say you know in support of getting a
appointed
counsel unless there's something on the
face of it that makes the makes the
judge say wait a minute this this
there's something wrong which is almost
never the
case the judges and the court system
they don't have any any uh uh
investigators to go out and or they have
neither the time nor the inclination to
go and check that so you sign off on it
and so there is really no you know un
unless you know I suppose if Bill Gates
came in and and filed an affidavit
seeking appointed counsel and somebody
said you know to the judge hey you know
that's Bill Gates out there maybe the
judge would do would would uh would do a
you know a further inquiry but that in
the real world where that doesn't happen
there isn't any further inquiry so if if
we don't have a situation where the
office of Cost Containment can actually
conduct an investigation to try to
collect money it will it will not happen
to
me the the whole idea of of the original
bill is what you know is based on I
guess what I would say it's the it's the
the sort of B discrimination of low
expectations it basically says you know
if you're if you're one of those poor
people we can't expect very much from
you we can't expect you to have to you
know uh live up to your financial
obligations you're just we're just going
to have to you know uh uh uh bite the
bullet and pay for you and uh we don't
we shouldn't expect you to have to repay
even if you have the financial ability
to do that and bear in mind that is the
if there if the judge finds that there
isn't any Financial ability or if the co
office of Cost Containment finds that
there isn't any Financial ability then
that's fine um but but it shouldn't be
the case that there's just going to be
sort of no inquiry into that um so I
feel very strongly that that the
amendment is appropriate that it will
restore the law to where it was um prior
to 2020 um when there when the uh office
of cost containment was actually
collecting I think it was like $1.9
million or something like that it's a
fairly significant amount of money that
they were collecting um and so for those
reasons I uh hope you'll support the
amendment Mr chair representative
bur thank you um I
disagree and I want to
explain what happens on a non infrequent
basis Johnny is charged with with
burglary couple neighbors
said yeah we think that was Johnny who
was coming out of the house and pick him
out of a lineup Johnny is charged Johnny
is Indigent fills that a form so that he
can get with the Constitution guarantees
him which is a
lawyer unfortunately he sits in jail for
bail
reasons and weeks go by months go by and
someone else is picked up on some
similar
burglaries and that person confesses to
the other burglaries and
confesses to the charge for which
Johnny's been sitting in
jail so Johnny comes back into court
with his courta appointed lawyer and the
judge issues an apology on behalf of the
state and says we're really sorry you
know we know your life's been turned
upside down we know that uh your kids
now been investigated by Social Services
we know all the hars that have gone on
to you we can't repair them but we feel
bad about it and by the way on the way
out here's a bill for
$4,000 now we know you have no money but
we have a mechanism where we will done
you for the money based on our guess as
to your future ability to pay so not
only has the
state ruined your life not as only has
the state said it was wrong what
happened but we're going to bill you for
what we did and we're going to D you and
every time you change your address for
the next six years or whatever you
better tell us because you're required
by law to do so and it's etc etc if we
reach the point
now where we are
saying to a totally innocent Granite
stator who has done nothing wrong who
got caught up in the
system and saying who availed himself or
herself of a right
guaranteed by the US
Constitution and we're going to say who
who cares that you are innocent we are
above you we are the
government we are going to bill you for
what we did to you and I just think at a
very very fundamental level of who we
are at Granite Staters as granted
Staters that that is fundamentally wrong
and by the way we will do that to
children too who are charged with
delinquency and found oh they weren't
delin
and that kid that child is going to be
dunned until he or she reaches the age
of
majority there's something I just think
when we look at ourselves and say is
this the kind of society that we want I
hope people you know vote against this
amendment anyone else wish to be heard
representative
Smith thank you Mr chair um
I I I do want to begin by saying that I
hope you didn't
mean to
um speak uh
authoritatively on the motives of those
people who acted um five years ago to
change um the
existing uh law when you
um announce why those people in
support of the change reach that
decision I was
somewhat unnerved by the the the
possibility that that you were deciding
why we had made that decision I also um
noted that um you you refer to um uh who
was in
charge um by political party as you will
know I have problems
making um talking about Republicans and
Democrats as if we're diff different
species if I remember
correctly um the governor of the state
of n Hampshire at that point was in fact
a republican but perhaps I I I
my memory is wrong so that those are two
points that I want to make about your
opening statement the next point and
this won't surprise you I've often joked
about the fact that you can take a girl
out of Finance but you can't take
Finance out of the girl and you talked
about the uh the revenue that came in
before the change was made what you
didn't talk about is how much it cost
the state of New Hampshire to collect
whatever it was they collected so even
if one assumes that what they collected
was
appropriate nonetheless it cost the
state more to collect that
money than um than the revenue that came
in um and that's something that I think
again whether one is a Republican or a
Democrat um whatever
one's thoughts are on on fiscal policy
no one would think it makes sense unless
you have uh you're interested in in
retribution it makes no sense for the
state to spend more
to collect money then it's getting in
return so on financial reasons um I
think it makes no sense to um uh to
continue with this
program um if in fact your Amendment um
your Amendment and and uh
uh does not pass there is another
amendment which uh is prepared and it
was prepared um with the guidance of the
commissioner of administrative Services
as to how the department would like to
handle um what would be um a Financial
Plus for the Department that in order to
make sure that given these uh difficult
times um with for whatever reason um our
not having quite enough money to do what
we want to do why it would make sense to
get rid of this effort to take the few
people who who are continuing to work in
this area and be able to put them in
different jobs that come closer to
meeting the needs of the people of the
State and I would urge uh this committee
to vote down the amendment that has been
proposed so far to consider and I hope
accept the amendment that I would then
um present to the committee and to vote
to support um this legislation which
makes sense from a financial point of
view from a an administrative point of
view and if I dare say from a moral
point of view and
um
uh I hope that we can come to an
agreement that way thank you anyone else
wish to be heard so I guess the last the
point I the point I would make here I I
I I think it I particularly want to
respond to representative bur's point
because he he outlined all the you know
the how the the terrible situation of
the person in the circumstances that he
described but the problem is what about
what about you or me what about if we
are the per if it's our kid or you or me
that are the person in that circumstance
do we get to say once they arrest the
real burglar later that oh oh you know I
had to hire an attorney it cost me
$10,000 $20,000 whatever I want my money
back who do I go to for that there is no
provision in the law that allows that so
why is it for somebody and understand
it's somebody who can afford to pay
something why does somebody who can
afford to pay
something uh and and by the way under
this law does not change the fact that
the the the amount that can be collected
is is the is a a relatively small amount
of the uh the it's capped by what the
cost of a contract attorney would be uh
which is a relatively small amount but
why does a person who can afford to pay
that amount uh either all at once or
over time or whatever why do they get a
pass on that when you or I who
presumably would be charged much more in
the private Market we don't get to get
our money back if we were found not
guilty um again I I go back to the issue
that this is this is the sort of benign
discrimination of low expectations that
you know U it's just sort of um those
those poor people or or people that are
don't fit into sort of our class we
should just you know we we we just have
to sort of grit and bear it um we
shouldn't expect them to be uh to be to
be required to pay uh for their for for
what is otherwise their responsibility
it's the same I I have have to say on a
broader perspective it's the same thing
in so many areas that where where
there's a f I think a fundamental
philosophical disagreement you know do
why I I would say why should people um
uh uh you know for example young young
un unmarried without children men or
women who who are capable of working why
should they be eligible to get Medicaid
or not have to pay for it but some
people say oh no no it'll be it'll it'll
be too much of a hassle to require them
to to do it that kind of thing do the
question it seems to me is how much do
we want to
socialize um the provision of services
and I say in this area we should not do
that Mr chair Mr Mr chair yeah
representative
bur
I I think there are distinctions that
that need to be made uh when you or I
choose to hire an
attorney that's a choice we make that's
uh we can negotiate the price we can uh
have uh an uncle do it for us whatever
it is we're talking here about children
and and indigen adults who have a
constitutional right and what we're
talking about is making children and
adults pay for a constitutional right
we're not talking about that in the
context of adults at all mean you mean
mean I don't have if if I can afford to
pay for a lawyer I don't have a
constitutional right to have a lawyer
you have a constitutional right to have
a lawyer but there's no requirement that
a lawyer be
assigned okay the state does not have to
to do that and your general argument
yeah I think there probably is a
philosophic uh distinction I'm reminded
of Was A Tale of Two Cities or whatever
that uh that makes it clear that the
rich and the poor have the right to
sleep under bridges um equally and that
may be true but I'm not sure how that
addresses the issue of we're talking
about people with no money who are
dragged into a system for no bad acts of
their own and whether we feel right as a
society that the state wants their money
that we have Det determined already that
they do not have so I think it's you're
you're comparing apples and oranges
representative Smith um thank you um um
Mr chair you are entitled to your
opinion as each of us is entitled to our
opinion but none of us is
entitled to make up our own facts and I
would ask you if you could uh to support
your argument of bringing Medicaid in to
the issue if you could tell us in fact
who receives Medicaid in this state what
the age is of those people who receive
Medicaid what the um eligibility is of
those people who receive Medicaid and I
believe that the facts will show that
we're not talking here about able bodied
adults who are um just choosing to sit
at home and read romance novels and eat
Bon bonss and receive Medicaid that's
not who's receiving Medicaid so your
opinion I have no problem with but the
facts I do thank you well again I'm
sorry representative
Oregon I just want to point out the
fiscal note indicates that uh we're the
$754,000 to collect
$640,000 and 416 so it seems me we're
keeping the OCC we're losing the OCC is
losing money like um so I think this is
a uh not a good business proposition
keeping this um keeping this keeping
this open so it's not worth spending
750,000
to collect six you know we're better off
we can save $110,000 by just eliminating
the office so I think the OCC should go
the way of the penny and the nickel so
we should it's time to get rid of it so
thanks other any other comments seeing
none are we ready for oh I'm sorry
representative mcfar thank you Mr
Speaker if I may Mr Speaker I would just
inquire of Representative Burch even if
I were inclined to agree with any of the
arguments that he set
forward why then
would I think that it is more or less
unfair for that Indigent defendant who
is not convicted than the one who was
convicted what you're essentially
suggesting it seems to me is that not
only are you as representative Lynn set
you talks about setting uh the the the
rights of the Indigent defendants aside
from the rights of everyone else but you
are suggesting that this should now be
thank you for asking uh I tried in this
portion of the discussion to talk about
the
amendment and the amend a core part of
the amendment is to remove the
distinction between adding the uh the
requirement to pay for non-convicted
people so I try to address that I am in
favor of the overall Bill I'm a
co-sponsor and the uh amendment by
representative Smith that ends the
practice whether uh the person was
guilty or not uh mostly for the point of
view that uh in The Frugal state of our
economy uh spending and and this I
practiced in Vermont Vermont came to
this conclusion 20 years ago that it
made no sense to spend more money trying
to collect than you collect and that's
just a simple uh you know uh concept of
good government and but my argument here
was really basically on the amendment
itself thank you all right anyone else
all right I think then we're ready for
uh and I given the given the the state
of the debate I think I'm would make
sense to have a roll call vote on the
amendment so we're voting on um
Amendment 2025 5
0638 to uh HB 611 this is a vote on the
amendment only and I would ask the clerk
please Vice chairman Manion yes
representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative Farland yes
representative gzowski
yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative bur no representative
Paige no representative Manos no
representative tur no representative
Rambo
no Representative
berson
no and chairman Lynn yes
nay all right all right so we're now on
to the uh otpa uh the bill as amended by
20256 38 um anyone want to have anything
anything further to say
motion also have
am ah okay I would like to um introduce
my Amendment and ask the committee to
for everyone on the committee has
received a copy of this but I'm pass
out hard
[Music]
copy and would um speak to the amendment
am11 so um point of order yes uh I
haven't received a copy of 0611
H everyone should have sorry should have
received it in
uh on their email
account uh that was
sent last week and here was a hard copy
coming
second oh no I'm sorry Joe was it you
youit yeah okay that's yeah that's what
uh representative Smith um has Amendment
0 20256 111h um I take it you so move
that amendment I so is there a second
second um so it's moved by
representative Smith seconded by
bur all right and representative Smith
amendment to my Amendment um for those
of us who were um present when the bill
was heard um by the committee uh there
was a a discussion and during that
discussion the commissioner of
administrative
Services um
uh raised some issues and asked that the
committee consider um accepting
uh certain
um procedures that would be necessary to
make um what was the original bill um
come to fruition in the most um
effective and responsible way and on the
basis of that an amendment was prepared
0611 it is a uh totally a convenient uh
that the um amendment number is actually
the same as the bill number which I
think shows that somewhere in The Ether
this was a a good match and um that um
can't blame me for
digging deep on this and
um uh and all that this does is make an
efficient smooth operation for the
Department of administrative services
and um if you were to accept this
amendment I believe what would happen is
it would um as
the Second Amendment
Second Amendment is another good term
here as a second amendment it would um
replace in this case the First Amendment
but
only um in a limited way and it would
mean that we would then vote on this
and then vote on um the bill as
amended by 611
anyone else wish to be heard on the
amendment by representative Smith so I
guess what I would just say basically is
I mean I think it's obvious that this
this amendment was designed to go along
with the with the original Bill we've
now replaced the bill with the amendment
we've just voted on so I would urge uh
the body to reject this amendment um so
that we can then proceed to the main
Bill to a vote on the main bill with the
amendment we've already approved um
anyone else wish to be heard all right
so I'd ask the clerk then to call the
role please on Amendment
06118 Vice chairman Manion
no representative Alexander no
representative trip no representative
Andrew no Representative kutab
no representative Perez no clerk votes
no representative mcf Farin no
Representative gzowski
no representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
bur yes representative Paige yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson yes and chairman
Lynn
no eight Ys 10 Nays all right so the
motion fails all right we're now back to
uh the main motion otpa on the bill with
um Amendment
20256 38 anyone wish to be heard um
before we call the role all right so
then I'd ask the clerk to please call
the role on the uh otpa on the bill with
Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland
yes representative gzowski yes
representative Smith no
representative Horgan no representative
bur no representative Paige no
representative Manos no representative
tur no representative Rambo no
Representative berson
no and chairman Lynn
yes 10 y 8
all right um so I will write the uh the
report for the uh the majority um who
will write the report I will write the
report for the minority and it will be
OT
TP a with Amendment um
okay um the representative Birch would
like to do this oh all right I'm sorry
no you're not sorry I mean you can be
sorry I mean it's not you didn't do
anything
wrong Birch minority all right um
question represent bch just can you have
it by six o' I wouldn't be home by 6
after to be tomorrow morning or maybe
late
tonight later T late tonight all right
I'll get it to you tonight all right all
right good thank
you sorry yes oh getting a maybe getting
a step or two ahead of ourselves here
but like assuming the full house uh goes
with the um op to pass with your
Amendment um would this would this more
likely go to a money committee and if so
would it be Finance or ways and means I
I I mean my I think let me just make
sure this but I think this is an early
Bill I'm almost positive it is and so I
think it will go to finance yes um hang
on let me make
sure yeah well that just because it has
an FN doesn't mean that but let me just
on yeah 611 is an early bill so we we'll
go to finance okay thanks all right all
right um Mr chair if I could just um
thank the commissioner of the Department
of administrative services and the
deputy for taking time of their busy
schedule to be here um and to um observe
um obviously I'm not going to ask them
to speak to what we've done because they
certainly would not likely say anything
but um uh I do appreciate the fact that
they were here and um assume that they
will be there when Finance decides what
to do with the Department's budget
right right yes thank you thank you for
being here all right um next um I would
uh like to turn to um HB um
right so
um I'm going to recognize oh I'm sorry
done I'm going going to um again
recognize um myself and I would
move um otpa on uh House Bill 615 FN
with Amendment 2025
um H
um and I'd ask is there a
second
second all right so it's
um moved by uh representative Lyn
seconded by representative Perez and if
I could uh speak to the amendment first
um
um the the amendment basically makes for
lack of a better term uh sort of
technical changes to the language um
that um that
make basically clarify the the terms of
the original um of the original bill I
don't really um for example um there's a
there's a uh a more clear
reference um in uh to uh the
circumstances in which um an innoc in
which an innocent owner would not have
property forfeited um the the amendment
clarifies that language to some extent
um and let me just think of it what
uh there's also a provision that makes
it clear that if a that if a person um
is if a person has an interest in
property that is subject to seizure or
to forfeiture but is not the defendant
it the the amendment makes it clear that
that per if that person loses in the
trial court the person can take an
appeal um to a higher Court in
accordance with with the with uh the
state uh in accordance with the rules of
the court or the state state rules uh uh
State statutes that may deal with
appeals in civil cases so um I think the
amendment um is not
particularly um substantive it Mo it
mostly clarifies and makes uh more
understandable language in the original
bill um so that's I would support uh the
amendment representative Mana
representative
thank you Mr chair I don't have a copy
of the amendment and I'm wondering if
you have a copy that you could pass
around z uh 0320 H um you don't oh
um uh I I'm sorry I guess I thought
everybody did have copies long a long
time ago Mr chair it was it was handed
to the committee during the public
hearing okay um so um
I mean does everybody does everybody
have a copy of the amendment should I
think everybody I I mean I'm happy to
give you my copy representative Manos
but I think everybody um okay all right
so anybody else wish to be heard on the
amendment yes representative bur thank
you and my comment is really a question
to you um in order for a property to be
um forfeited
uh
the person has to have not have actual
knowledge and I want to get to why the
requirement of actual knowledge is in so
much of the law we use constructive
knowledge or had reason to believe but
here it's actual knowledge so if
somebody bars my car with a wink and a
nod and says I'm going to get some ice
cream
and you kind of know dog on well they're
not going to get some ice cream but
you're all allly in free for getting
your car back unless you can act prove
that I actually knew exactly what they
were going to do I'm just wondering why
that standard yeah so you know I guess
what I would say is this I think I'm not
sure that in the wink and the nod
situation that wouldn't amount to act
you know there is this uh the this idea
in the law of willful blindness that if
you if you if you really do know but you
try to sort of You Know cover your face
that that's that that is not that that
would not undercut there being actual
knowledge but the broader issue is I
think the whole idea of this
bill was
to make forfeiture
proceedings
um more for lack of a better term more
owners for the state to to sustain
forfeitures it was designed to be a sort
of defendant and uh property owner
friendly bill to make the law more you
know more hospitable uh to um to people
whose property is subject to forfeiture
and I think it's in that spirit that
that language was included um there you
know for example
um in under a current forfeiture law
there is a provision that says if your
if your let's say your car is used to
deliver
drugs um you some somebody who's the
defendant in the case uses your car to
deliver drugs you claim and then and
then the the police for uh sees the car
and they propose to Forfeit it you
claim I I didn't know I didn't know you
know I I didn't know that uh
uh my friend John Smith who was who
delivered the drugs was going to use it
to deliver drugs under our current
forfeit your law you bear the burden of
establishing that you are an innocent
that you that in fact you didn't know
this this bill changes that it's the
state that bears the burden it it
eliminates that um that uh provision
that shifts the burden um I mean that's
just that's one example um but there are
a number of other things it has
Provisions that allow um that say for uh
forfeiture can't be allowed for uh
currency totaling $1,000 or less or
Motor Vehicles of value of $5,000 or
less um
um basically to sort of and again I
assume that part of the issue there that
that that what we're getting at there is
if they're if if somebody's going to be
charged with a crime and they're going
to and they're going to be facing um the
penalties of of the drug offenses which
can themselves be particularly serious
that if it's a relatively small amount
of uh property or uh or money that um
that the state shouldn't be allowed to
proceed with the forfeiture so those are
those are the U those are the basic
ideas
one one further question if I may sure
the following sentence says the states
Sam summarily shall return property to
such
person I I think if I understand the
overall bill that's not so
necessarily because that property may
need to be used in a parallel criminal
prosecution and the like but I'm
concerned about that language which
seems which is both mandatory and
doesn't seem subject to uh uh other uses
the state might have in a criminal case
for hanging on to that property well I
think there is I'm sorry in other places
I think that's covered but I'm just
wondering why the sentence is in there
because it now you're going to build
it's got two different ways uh if I'm an
innocent owner I'm going to say hey I
want my property back now I don't care
about your criminal prosecution says
State sarily shall return the property
right right but I I mean I think that
that's that that the state shall
summarily return the property if there's
if there's no if if it in fact is
established that you're an innocent
owner if there's a question about
whether you really are then that's then
you know no even if you are an innocent
owner right the state may need that car
or whatever that's been seized for his
criminal case oh but you know what
there's other Provisions in the bill
that say you can take you can like you
know right so then it's not sarily I'm
just worried about the language here
which Brooks no
exception I understand other parts of
the bill allow the
exception I guess I would say I think
that that language would I think that
the that that can be read consistently
with the other language thank you um all
right um other um other
questions um on I guess we're talking
about the amendment only right now
anyone else have any questions on the
amendment so um seeing none I would ask
that the clerk call the rooll on
Amendment 2025
0320 um and the motion is uh to to uh
amend Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab
yes representative Perez yes clerk votes
yes representative McFarland yes
representative gzowski
amendment
um no
Representative hgan
no representative Birch
Paige representative Manos
no representative
tur
Rambo
no Representative berson
no and chairman Lynn yes
10 Ys eight Nays all right the amendment
passes
um all right so then turning to the uh
main motion I would
move um ought to pass on the on the bill
as amended is there um a
second all right so move by
representative Lynn second by
representative
second all right
um I really I I really have I don't
think I have much else to say um than
what I said before basically this bill
is designed
to for lack of a better term sort of
take the the um the edge off forfeitures
to make it somewhat less honorous than
it is under current law
to allow for certain exceptions for
small amounts of uh of uh of money or
property um to uh and oh and the other
thing the other thing that this bill
does it's it really importantly is it
says that
although the the forfeiture proceeding
is a separate proceeding from the
criminal case it's a separate civil
proceeding it will be handled by the
same judge that handles the criminal
proceeding um and that the public
defender
um will represent the person in the
forfeiture will represent the defendant
not not some third party who might be
claiming Innocent but we represent the
defendant in the proceeding so it's
basically designed as I said before to
to uh make forfeiture proceedings
somewhat less onerous um somewhat more
favorable to either the defendant or a
person whose property is being subject
to forfeiture I think it makes sense to
do that um and that's why I support it
um anyone else wish to be
heard all right seeing none I'd ask the
clerk then to call the
role Vice chairman Manion no
representative Alexander no
representative trip
yes representative Andrew
no Representative kutab
no didn't she move I
you clerk votes no representative
McFarland
yes Representative gzowski
no representative Smith
no representative Horgan no
representative Bur
no representative Paige
no representative Manos
no representative tur
no representative Rambo
no Representative berson
no and chairman Lynn
yes for y 14
ump fails all right is there another
so I'm sorry represent Manos you
seconded y okay all right all right so
it's been uh moved by representative
Smith uh seconded by representative
Manos uh to itl anybody wish to be heard
further on the
bill not seeing seeing that I'd ask the
clerk to call the role on the itl motion
representative Manion yes representative
Alexander yes representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
Perez
no CL clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
no representative gzowski yes
representative Smith
yes representative Horgan yeah
yes representative Burch yes
representative Paige
yes representative Manos
yes representative tur
yes representative Rambo
yes representative berson
no 15 Ys and three Nays did I do that
correct three I think that I miss
somebody did I
do
okay all right all right all right so um
report representative Alexander is quite
amused by the fact that I'm now going to
have to say I
will all right
um I guess what I what I would say is
this um although I am a uh uh co-sponsor
of this bill representative Maguire is
the main person so if there's going to
be a Minority Report it will be written
by representative Maguire and I will let
you know whether that will happen or not
Mr I don't think yeah he's not a member
oh I'm sorry he has to be on the
committee okay um we just put this
on right could we just put this on
consent and not rate a report there's
only
three no I don't want to I don't want to
do that I would object so I I'll write
minority that's true that that's true um
yeah no I I hear
um you can decide you're in Char right I
think I will I think I probably will
write a Minority Report all
right all
right
uh all right so that takes care of
um all right next I'm gonna oh I'm sorry
you know what we're going to take a u uh
a like a 10-minute break for uh uh
Necessities that need to need to uh
happen
so we could well I don't know what do
what do people think you want to take
you want to um take a lunch break or
keep
going i' say let's let's take a lunch
break now come back I think lot let's
let's take let's take uh 10 minutes or
so and come back and let's just finish
it up we have other things to do finish
everything up finish
yeah one 2 3 four 5 6
I think I think many of are
have
e
all right I'm going to uh call the
committee back to order and I'm going to
next take up uh for the executive
session
cacr 6 and I would recognize uh
representative McFarland for a motion I
move ought to pass is there a second
I'll second I representative McFarland
you wish to speak to your motion I'll
speak briefly I I I know we're in a
hurry to get through here and I think
we've already discussed the issues in
the hearing uh but I do believe that
it's appropriate for us to recognize the
right uh to uh keep and be computers and
to use them uh in in general purpose
ways uh including for encryption um so
I'm I'm supportive of this motion all
right anyone else wish to be heard ni
yes representative
chair cacr 6
yeah okay yes yeah
absolutely I have two con two problems
with with the bill small and
large the bill itself has two the cacr
itself has two
sentences one the right to freely use
Etc shall not be infringed which seems
to be an
absolute but then the second sentence
says you can infringe under law laws and
regulations if they are considered
reasonable whatever that word means so
we have a first sentence that is not
consistent with a second sentence let's
put that aside a
bit my concern about the cacr is the
potential misuse of the
cacr by people who commit crimes serious
crimes through the use of
computers so we could talk about if we
like
pedophiles who commit horrible crimes
against
children by use of
computers but according to this
cacr their right to use that computer
shall not be
infringed
so you get somebody arrested for let's
say Interstate crime against children we
have a whole division in the state that
deals with that that person is arrested
in New Hampshire for using a computer
to uh improperly associate with
children and they're
charged the judge normally now would
restrict as a bail condition that
person's use of a
computer now a judge under this cacr if
pay P presumably would not be able to do
so and that's not a good thing my mind
secondly we talk about we had a fairly
famous person in Keen who did romance
scams to tune of millions of dollars
using computers Bitcoins and the like uh
he's now sitting in federal
prison now I am sure as a condition of
his sentence
that he is barred for uses certain usage
of a computer during his prison sentence
I
would think if he were incarcerated in
New
Hampshire at the right of individuals to
freely use computational resources would
allow him to continue doing
whatever scams and the like that he
would want to
do so I think I would have a hard time
explaining my to my
constituents why I would like New
Hampshire to be a place where all the
pedophiles can feel
comfortable coming here and applying
their business or why people who have
been let's say convicted in other states
and barred from certain uses of
computers can feel comfortable moving to
New Hampshire and um continuing to do
whatever got them barred from using
computers in other states so while I
like the general idea I think this
constitutional amendment is not ready
for Prime Time Mr Speaker may I respond
to those points yeah let me just ask
anybody else wish to be heard all right
no representative McFarland go ahead
thank you so Mr Speaker first of all to
representative bur's point about the
language of the proposed Constitutional
Amendment
itself uh I don't think that the
language is perfect uh for example I am
not a fan of split infinitives and I
would quite like to amend it so that
instead of saying to freely access it
says freely to access however I think it
is good enough for the purpose and and
you make the point um or representative
Birch rather makes the point that the
second sentence in his view uh is in
conflict with the first and I I suggest
to the committee that that is not the
case the first sentence is a broad
statement as to the right and the second
statement is a slightly narrower
statement which in no way conflicts with
the first it does not say that it would
be appropriate to burden that right it
merely makes it abundantly clear that
one of the effects of this
constitutional amendment should be that
there would be no law or regulation that
unreasonably burdens the right if I make
comparison to the Second Amendment I
have not heard any of the most strong
and Ardent Second Amendment supporters
suggest that it is appropriate that
incarcerated prisoners should be allowed
to roam the jails and roam the prisons
with loaded
AK-47s so I I think if we're going to be
serious about this and if you want me to
come to your second point about this you
know supposed parade of of pedophiles
that are going to come to the state we
need to be
realistic that reasonable restrictions
exist upon other constitutionally
protected freedoms and that this one
ultimately should be no different what
we have however seen both in this state
and in this nation is not merely as uh
the B sponsor talked about uh actions by
for example the Biden Administration
against uh people who would potentially
have a large amount of compute for AI
purposes or be doing it in a way that is
not considered sufficiently green but we
have seen a history of other uh attempts
to to block and thwart uh the free use
of computers and and the free use of
secure encryption so for those reasons I
would urge the committee to support the
bill right anyone else wish to be
heard I'm sorry represent Oran do you
want to speak oh yes I do yes um first
of all I'm glad uh the member from
Orange brought up the Second Amendment
because that language I think is
problematic so it's been misin
interpreted not so much by the uh courts
but by like you know by you know
individuals a political spear like us to
being that like I guess there maybe
unless you're a prisoner incarcerated
you some people think the Second
Amendment says you're supposed to be
able to have a gun anywhere for any
purpose and as somebody uses
computers a lot of time that would be
kind of cool if I could use my computer
anyway I wanted anyway you know for any
purpose you know like uh and somebody
doesn't like when I'm doing computer you
know they can just go stuff it so that
kind of appealing but still the language
I think is problematic um he mentioned
the Biden Administration who of course
are no longer in power and uh Supply
certain us of AI are insufficiently
green um that's that's a pretty
legitimate concern aside from just
certain ai ai Technologies or
the problematic in terms of uh how they
use copyrighted uh intellectual property
but also like just in terms of energy
consumption we've had problems with
Bitcoin and other Technologies even
though they're very interesting in doing
groovy sometimes they do waste use a
huge amounts of power I think the
government does have an interest in you
know conserving uh you know conserving
energy at least at some point the
government will think it has an interest
in it and U so I understand uh they
echoing the Second Amendment it is part
of our constitution in fact it's about
the only part of my con Constitution and
I'm
sure that we haven't tried to redefine
or you know there haven't been any
executive orders related to trying to
like redefine what the Second Amendment
means so maybe it's the only part of the
constitu Federal Constitution that's
left but I still think that's
uh you know I still think this is just
something it shouldn't be in the I'm not
sure this is as written as a good
addition to the State Constitution and
um also we can't the people can't vote
on this until November 202 six so
there's no rush we have
uh we have plenty I mean we have lots of
other things to do but we have plenty of
time to retain this bill if and uh try
to come up with more acceptable language
although I'm
personally even if you reord this I
don't think there something who needs to
be in the State Constitution and
certainly I certainly was sympathetic by
the way to what the bid administration's
concerned about AI not being green
enough even though um you know it's very
interesting even though some ways a lot
of that technology very interesting but
I'm uh we seem to be getting a little
bit off the topic well I'm just
responding to what he said but I just I
think the main thing is uh I think
everybody seems to agree that there's
problems with the language nobody's
really enthusiastic about putting the
state constitutions I don't think if the
point is to do something about this uh
we we can probably think about this some
more and uh you know consider it bring
something to the floor next year we
don't have to do it this year since
nobody
we can't the people can't vote on it
until next year anyway there's no hurry
so all right anyone else wish should be
heard uh representative tur and then
representative bur yeah thank thank you
um I
think being that this is a
constitutional amendment proposition it
raises to a different level sort of the
degree to which we have to focus on what
the
underlying threat that were basically
worried about to our rights is and
listening to the bill
sponsor you referred to you know
essentially a federal requirement to
register certain
services to my understanding that that
does not require or allow any sort of
restriction about it it's just a
registration process and we didn't
really hear any examples in the hearing
of anyone's ability
to use comp computational Services being
being spelled out in any sort of
functional way it feels like the minimum
bar before we start putting a
constitutional amendment before the
citizens of the state would be to
basically
establish a real threat um and then you
know if we get past that hurdle the
language here to me seems fairly wide
open and undefined there's no guard
rails on this it basically freely access
use and employ computational
resources does not in any
way
Define it it seems to undermine the
basic concepts around around network
security around um you know Network
governance and ownership I it feels like
there could be big unintended
consequences if someone could basically
say any restriction on their ability to
compute could be could be interpreted as
a violation of the State Constitution so
I I do not support this so is there
anyone represent bch I know you want to
speak is there you've spoken before so
I'm and I'm not going to stop you from
speaking but I just want to see before
we get to you if there's anyone else who
wants you to speak yeah all right go
ahead I got it uh two thoughts and I'd
like to to address uh my friend from
across the aisle
um am I correct in assuming that from
what you said the language shall not be
infringed doesn't really mean shall not
be infringed it's subject to all kinds
of other things that you talked about
and I'm concerned that we've had decades
upon decades if not centuries of
litigation in the Second Amendment World
about that unfortunate language whether
you're on one side of the issue or the
other so
so if you agree that shall not be
infringed doesn't really mean shall not
be infringed but will be subject to
endless
correctly Mr Speaker I guess I would ask
you whether or not we might have a show
of hands as to sentiment on this because
I I could be persuaded to withdraw my
motion and make a motion to retain um
how how many people here uh might we
find out hang on hang on hang on the the
uh the mo the
um well no that all right that's a fair
point how many the motion has been to
ought to pass if there's a if you're
suggesting that might make more sense to
retain this um sure let's have a show of
hands how many people would support
okay how about OTP what's that how many
people would support
OTP I'm sorry I was just wondering how
many people would support OTP oh how
many people would oppose
retain all right so you want to withdraw
your
motion I I was just trying to assess Mr
Mr chairman how many people might be in
support of the original OTP motion it
seems that there may not be a
plurality no no no we didn't you didn't
ask the qu if if you want to know how
many people would support on a straw
vote how many people would support OTP I
think that's a different question that's
OTP all right so it it appears that we
not that we would not have a majority to
do that Mr Speaker I would uh be obliged
if if you let me withdraw my motion and
submit an alternative motion to retain
this cacr I would allow you to do that
so a motion is to retain is there a
second is there a second to
retain all right so motion is to retain
and it's uh made hang on one
second made by representative uh
McFarland seconded by
representative um
um anybody wish to say anything further
about right then I'll represented Manos
just I just have a question um if retain
fails will we get to
itl if retain fails
um depends on what motion is uh what
motion is made next um so uh all right
so the motion before us is the motion to
retain um cacr 6 um I'd ask the clerk to
please call the
role Vice chairman Manion yes
representative
Alexander representative trip
yes representative Andrew yes
representative kutab yes representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes
representa representative guzowski yes
representative
Smith representative Horgan yes
representative bur yes representative
Paige
yes representative Manos
yes representative tur
yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson
yes and chairman Lynn
yes 18 y zero Nays all right all right
and no one has to write a report right
all right so I'm going to turn now to
take up H uh CA
CR7 and the chair recognizes
motion thank you I'd like to make a
um all right representative Robo would
you do you wish to speak to your motion
uh just briefly yes um we understood
from testimony in the hearing that with
regard to criminal standards this would
simply it's it's already in Lo the
presumption of innocence it would upend
entirely the standard for civil
proceedings um and proof Beyond
Reasonable Doubt thank you and and so we
just didn't hear any need to my opinion
we did not hear any need in the hearing
to make this sort of change all right
anyone else wish to be
heard I I guess I would say I I I think
I agree with you completely on on your
your view on this um all right so uh I
guess we're ready to call the role uh
the motion is uh on ccr7
itl um and I'd ask the clerk to please
call the
role Vice chairman Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrews yes Representative kutab no
representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
yes representative Smith
yes representative Horan
yes representative Burch
yes representative Paige
yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo
yes representative berson yes
um uh so representative Rambo can I ask
you to write the uh report all right
and well that's I was goingon to ask and
this any anyone object to this going on
consent seeing none it can be on consent
um
all right
um next
um
HB um
um yeah
62 oh well no you know what I'm I'm
sorry you're right you're absolutely
right we did Skip yep no no no no you're
did you're right we did Skip
762 sorry thank
you
yeah
72 yeah so right so I all right on 762
uh the chair recognizes representative
Alexander for a motion thank you Mr
chair I move in expedient to legislate
second I second the motion all motion
made by uh representative uh Alexander
seconded by uh representative Andress
representative Alexander do you wish to
speak to your motion yeah yeah briefly
this bill would appropriate $30,000 to
the Judiciary for hiring a contractor to
review domestic violence and stalking
cases for the purposes of gathering data
um the bill just lacks specificity
regarding the type of data to be
collected and its intended use um we
already feel or I feel that
transitioning to electronic filing is
going to solve a lot of these problems I
think the Court's already working on
that so um I don't think this bill is
needed all right anyone else wish to be
heard representative Manos yes thank you
Mr chair I actually have an amendment to
this bill which I circulated um and
everybody has a copy of it and um I
would like to move my Amendment um you
can't you can't now well right I I
wanted to be recognized I I thought I
had been um granted the
um the uh ability to be recognized um
but if I then I will speak to um
representative Alex what Al what
representative Alexander said if I may
um my Amendment which uh I won't move
yet because I haven't been uh recognized
to do that but my Amendment would
address the issue that representative
Alexander raised and which was raised in
the hearing on my bill uh which is the
lack of specificity about what data
would be collected and my Amendment
specifies what data it is um I also
wanted to address the issue of
electronic filing um electronic filing
is not done at this time in domestic
violence cases and the judicial branch
does not have the funding to um proceed
with electronic filing there are also
concerns about whether some victims of
domestic violence who want to file may
not have access to electronic filing or
may fear for their safety in the process
of filing electronically so I think
ultimately that uh in the future when
the court system moves toward electronic
filing and domestic violence cases that
hopefully there will also be an
alternative to um for victims to
continue to file paper on paper um so I
would um oppose represented I would
oppose the motion of
itl um and
um the other thing that my um Amendment
would do is to um add some language
about
supplementation which was requested by
the judicial branch so I would oppose
the itl all right anyone else wish to be
heard I hear seeing no seeing none uh I
would ask the clerk to call the role the
motion uh before us is itl on House Bill
representative Manion
yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland
yes representative gzowski
yes representative Smith
no representative Horgan no
representative Burke
no representative Paige no
representative Manos
no representative tur no representative
Rambo no Representative berson no
chairman Lynn
yes 10 y eight Nays all right all right
so the motion passes itl representative
Alexander can I ask you to write the
report yes all right will there be a
Minority Report yes right represent
amendment um and you know I don't have
any problem if that can that be done or
does that have to be done as the floor
it can okay all right all right that's
fine minority okay all right all right
um that takes care of
762 um next I'd like to uh turn to uh
House Bill
um
and
all
right and excuse me Mr chair can I just
ask representative Manus a question
about the amendment sure the number yeah
so I have it right 0576
um okay um so I'm turning to uh house
bill
um 88 hang on one
that
um all right and so um I would move
ought to pass
with two
amendments
um no I know I understand I assume we do
have to do two um so I I I guess what I
would say is I would um move ought to
pass uh first with Amendment
20257 H and is there a
second second by representative uh Perez
all right um and if I could speak uh
just briefly to uh the am the amendment
um the amendment in question prepared by
representative Maguire is basically
designed to make it clear that the that
the establishment of the Community
Property Trust um is not to be in
derogation of the rights of any
creditors or people who have uh uh
some uh lean or other security interest
in the property it it um I think if I
recall correctly from the hearing I
think representative Burch you may have
suggested that this needed to be done I
think representative Maguire agreed and
and did that um so I think the amendment
uh makes perfect sense um and I ask you
to support the amendment anyone else
wish to be heard on the
amendment all right um then um is that
something we can do by a show of hand
on on the amendment um so all those in
favor this is on the amendment only all
those in favor of amendment
hand representative trip okay um let me
just make sure I think we are unanimous
all right so um on that Amendment we're
unanimous um hang on I just want to make
all right then next I would turn to
Amendment um uh
015h which is uh representative burch's
Amendment and I would move that
that all right
second Alexander all right um and so on
this
um on
uh this amendment uh basically this uh
this deletes section one of the bill
which I think would have would have if
we hadn't removed that it would have uh
impacted the real estate transfer tax is
that correct and so uh representative
Burch
correctly uh representative McGuire
agreed uh removed section one and
redesignated sections two and three as
sections one and two again very common
sense amendment made perfect sense um
anybody have any want anyone want to
speak to that
amendment I see none can I again can I
call for a show of hands um all those in
favor of amendment
hand anyone opposed all right so that
Amendment again if uh
um all right so now we're on to the to
the main motion um the bill with with
those two
amendments um and um I would move um
ought to pass uh with those amendments
second all right so
um moved
by um representative Lynn seconded by uh
representative
Perez
um and I guess I would like to speak to
uh the motion uh just briefly um I think
this bill makes sense um as I and I I
have to say this was an area of the law
that I was not uh I'm not a tax lawyer I
was not particularly familiar with but
um basically as I recall the
testimony um it you have a situation
where if the if you have a community
property if you have a law like this
established and I the example that I
recall from the testimony was you have
this situation husband and wife um have
property in a trust that is not a
community property Trust
husband dies the property goes to the
wife wife now wants to convey the
property um to some third person um
under the as I understand it under if
it's not Community Property Trust what
the IRS will say is
okay that Pro the the the portion of
that property which represents the
deceased husband's interest the wife
gets a stepped up basis in that property
so that if she then sells the property
there is no capital gains tax on
um let's assume in my example she sells
it immediately so there's no further
rise in the property while she owns it
so there's there's there's no capital
gains tax on the portion of the sale of
the property that represents the
husbands
the deceased husband's interest because
there's a stepped up basis in that but
the portion that represents the wife's
interest from before there that is not
subject to the stepped up basis and so
the um for that part of the property the
the wife has to pay the capital gains
tax on the the difference between the
value when the property was acquired and
the value when it was sold
whereas if the commun if this was in a
community property
trust the way the IRS would treat this
is there would be no capital gains tax
due at all um it seems to me that for
people and you know and this bill
doesn't require anybody to have a a a
community property trust but it seems to
me that um to allow people to take
advantage of a community property trust
in that circumstance makes sense why
should they why shouldn't they be able
to avoid having to pay the tax which uh
uh you know I think if I recall
correctly there representative Burch you
may correct me if I'm wrong but I
thought that representative Maguire said
there's like 15 states or something that
have this um I think that's right I
don't know but I think I mean it's a
number of states have it so it seems it
seems to me that this makes sense I I'm
not sure I understand what would be the
argument of not doing this um unless you
know unless you want people to pay more
taxes maybe that's that's okay uh but
representative Manos
um I'd like to make the argument against
the bill um so my concern is from the
perspective of an attorney who practices
family law and um it's clear on uh page
one of the
bill um line 16 that dissolution which
mean would mean dissolution of the
Community Property Trust would include
divorce among other um other uh terms
here and then it says on page three of
the bill on line 10 dissolution of
marriage termination of trust upon the
dissolution of the marriage of the
settler spouses the Community Property
Trust shall terminate and the trustee
shall distribute one half of the trust
assets to each spouse with each spouse
receiving one half of each asset unless
otherwise agreed to in writing by both
spouses what that implies to me um is
that the Court would lose jurisdiction
over treating the asset as a marital
asset and being able to equitably
divided in the circumstance of a divorce
or dissolution of the marriage for other
reasons um this to me from my
perspective basically would turn not
basically would turn New Hampshire into
a community property State for the
purposes of divorce um
and I strongly oppose that so um I don't
support this bill I don't support this
so you know I guess I'm not clear so
let's assume that you're right that it
would turn it in what what do you say
are the implications of that this is a
as I understand that these are these
trusts are revocable trusts so the as I
understand I think it's pretty clear the
court can do whatever it wants with a
revocable trust I I think as um as
page three lines 10 through 13 I think
make it clear that the court would lose
jurisdiction over being able to
equitably divide the marital property um
viewing this as marital property and
being able to equitably divide it I
think the other thing is um and I think
the other way in which that's emphasized
is on page two lines 7 through 11 which
make it
clear
um that there is legal risk here in in
uh entering into such an agreement um I
am also not a tax attorney and I I so I
don't know tax law but it it seems to
me if I think about my own family that
if a if a um house is own joint
if the marital home is owned jointly and
one of the spouses
dies that the other
spouse does receive a steed up basis so
I'm not and that the sale of the house
by the Survivor spouse is
a non- taxable event is and I could be
very well be wrong about that but that's
my memory from my own family
situation but I don't know but anyway
for those reasons I oppose this this
bill anyone else wish to be heard on on
the bill right so I guess I would say
the only thing I would say about that I
I just I I do not see how you could read
the language that you're saying to to to
sort of house the court of its
jurisdiction to um to divide property
that's in a that's in a revocable trust
I mean I just don't I I don't think that
I don't I think the court would retain
that that language would not in any way
prevent the court from from having the
jurisdiction to to you know do whatever
it felt was Equitable in the
circumstances again if I may it it says
unless otherwise agreed to uh this is
line 13 on page three unless otherwise
agreed to in writing by both spouses so
it seems to me that um unless there's a
mutual agreement by the spouses on
divorce that again that the court is
deprived of jurisdiction to me this
would be analogous to the situation
where the court and I can't remember if
you were on the court at the time of
this decision but the decision that said
unless spouses agree to the payment of
postsecondary education for their minor
children that the court uh that the
court does not have the ability to order
parents to pay for postsecondary
education
now parents can agree that they will but
if they don't then the court can't order
them to and I would I would view this as
an AAL an
analogous
situation um so that raises concerns for
me okay all right I I I guess I don't I
don't see it but that's that's fine
that's your view um all right anyone
else wish to be heard on
this all right so the motion then is
otpa with the two amendments and I'd ask
please Vice chairman Manion yes
representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andress
no representative kutab
yes representative Perez
yes clerk votes yes representative
yes representative Smith
no representative Horan
no representative Burch
no representative Paige no
no representative Manos no
representative tur no representative
Rambo no representative
and chairman Lynn
nay um all right so
um uh I guess I will write the uh the
uh ma the Min majority report um who
wants to write The Minority
Report representative Manos all right um
okay
um
manity all right um here of
88 um all right um next uh I'm going to
turn to let me make sure I just want to
be wary of the time representative Perez
what can representative Perez I'm sorry
can I just say what what time is it that
you need to be out of
here okay all right yeah no no no that's
fine all right so I'm going to take up
then next uh uh House Bill uh
199 and I would recognize representative
Smith for a
motion oh wait what are we do uh House
Bill 199 extending the statute of
limitations for past I would recognize
you for a
motion all right um it's moved by
representative uh Smith ought to pass is
there a
second yes second by representative
buron okay hang on
um
second on all right representative Smith
motion just uh very briefly this is an
issue which has been before this
committee um if I hope I don't offend
anyone when I say
adium and it is because it is an issue
which um is unbelievably
serious and um in which we have uh
constantly finding out um new realities
about the situation in which the
pest
chemicals um have created uh serious
life affecting problems
some of which are
not are not
actually visible or
um
knowing um for a number of years
particularly those affecting
children where it is not until uh they
enter puberty or later where um it is
possible to discover the serious damage
that has been done all that this bill
does is recognize
reality and um ask that we extend um for
a a reasonable period of
time uh the
uh the opportunity for people affected
negatively by pasas to seek
redress all right anyone else um wish to
be heard on this representative
tur yeah I just wanted to highlight you
know from our testimony on this bill um
the distinction that I believe was made
in terms of when you acknowledge or
should be able to know that you had been
exposed versus the statute of
limitations when you might actually be
able to bring successfully or decide
that you have enough uh evidence
available to bring successfully a um a
suit under under that um
requirement in an area like this it's
not it was mentioned that that you know
over a certain period of time the
evidence gets gets stale and stagnant
and the witnesses this is not a once
this is not an event that happens to
someone at one point in time um you know
like being hit by a car this is
something where
the fact of your exposure and your
damage takes a long time to understand
and probably takes even longer than that
to um to reach the point where you
believe you reasonably have enough uh
accumulated knowledge or science to
prove that that your injury was related
so I think it's different than a lot of
other statute of limitation cas es and
the analogies that were presented I
think don't really apply so I I think
this would be reasonable and unlike in
the past it doesn't leave the window
open forever it just extends it right
anyone else wish to be heard all right
so I guess what I would say is I I know
I I my my sense is that that on my side
of the aisle that we are split on this
to some extent my I plan to vote against
this bill for this reason I think that
um the um I don't disagree with what you
said representative Tura that there are
you know that there could be that there
that injuries in this kind of situation
are different than say a car accident or
something like that which is a discreet
event but there are many me I I um I I
the example that comes to mind is
asbestos cases um there you know th
those those cases in fact those they've
been going on for decades and and in
fact there are still some asbestos cases
that that um that uh are brought now
involving uh exposures that happened
years and years and years ago another
example of that might be um the YDC
cases I mean there are Casa those those
cases go back decades um and and involve
at least as as to the claims against the
state as opposed to against particular
um officers uh but it claims against the
state um it it really is sort of a
similar thing because the claim the the
basis of the theory of liability against
the state is well maybe at maybe at you
know some discret time the state
shouldn't have known that there that the
abuse was going on but at some point
they the state did the state should have
known and and it was reasonable for them
to have done something so I think that
um the way the discovery rule Works
whether the statute of limitations is
three years or six years or 20 years or
um well I guess it wouldn't apply might
be different if it was never but
whatever the length of the statute of
limitations is what you're basically
saying given the discovery rule is
whoever the injured person is once they
know or should know that they've been
injured and they know or should know
that it was caused by the person uh by
the business or entity that um was
involved in past that they they have the
period of the statute of limitations to
then sit on their hands and do nothing
and it just doesn't seem to me that it
makes sense where the statute of
limitations doesn't start to run until
you know or should know that you've been
injured and you know or should know that
it's caused by the defendant you're
planning to Sue that if once you know
those two things you should be able to
sit on your hands for 20 years it's
sitting on your hands for six years it
seems to me is already twice what the
usual statute of limitations is to now
extend that to 20 years I just don't I
just don't understand the basis for that
representative Smith uh thank you um
very much could you explain to me why
why you would
suggest that
anyone
would um sit on their hands for a year
two years 10 years 20 years um once it
became clear to them that the problems
they were facing in terms of health
related issues which is what we're
talking about um were likely caused by
pasas um
I I'm having trouble imagining unless I
were really
really I don't know and it's not even a
question of cynicism uh why would
anybody sit on their hands isn't it a
question of when they find out or when
they realize or when the connections are
made that they
um that they can act um I can't see what
anyone would stand to
gain by sitting on their hands am I am I
missing something well I know I I mean I
I I I think the problem is that you're I
think what you're missing if to the
extent you say that is the way the
discovery rule operates because it it
gives you it doesn't the statute doesn't
start to run until those things two
things that I said before were were
exist and so given that you know whether
the statute is 6 years or 20 years
doesn't really make much difference in
terms of of fairness to the person
that's been injured because you have
that time I mean that's why as I say the
yd that's why the YDC cases as far as I
know the statute of limitations from the
YDC cases is three years but the the
injuries that that happened there were
happened happened in the late 80s or
even earlier some of them I think go
back and as far as maybe the 60s but
those people have been able to bring CL
claims because they were relying on the
Discovery rule even under the three-year
statute of limitation so I guess what
I'm really saying is I don't see the
need I mean it you know I completely
agree that P is a huge problem um but I
don't think that it makes sense to have
a special rule that doesn't really
accomplish very much
because because of the Discovery that's
that's my view Mr
shair yes uh well let me see
representative Perez then representative
bur then representative McFarland
representative Perez need and harm there
may not be a need for it but people who
do not understand that the statute that
it starts at the discovery those of us
that are not lawyers may look at this
law and say and read it and say it says
um it's it's six years oh it's been
longer than six years so I can't do it
as far as I'm concerned there's no harm
in putting it as far as I'm concerned we
are going to have more than Past coming
up with these um problems there's going
to be a lot of things that are going to
come up that are going to have to be
extended extended it's certainly not
going to be long enough for all the
things that are happening to Children
right now to be only three years of a
statue so I don't see the harm in doing
this representative Burch
you
suggested that we shouldn't have a
special rule for this as opposed to
other similar kind of
cases my suggestion is that statute of
statutes of
limitation are themselves a Special Rule
so we start with the general
proposition that everybody is entitled
to their day in court
and I think as a general proposition we
should be able to agree on that concept
that everybody's entitled to their day
in court statutes of limitation which
are increasingly falling out of
favor say well there should be some
limitation because the memory of people
fade over time the access to Witnesses
fade over time now keep in mind that's
PE people stuff that's not documents
it's not records and the like so as we
develop in the informational age more
and more ways of documenting things and
more and more ways of preserving
knowledge the need for for limited
statutes of limitation get less and less
which is why they're being expanded
across the board you bring up the idea
of the uh the
YDC but we also know that in cases for
instance of sexual assault we are
expanding and expanding and expanding
the statute of limitation because of a
variety of reasons a lot of people who
are sexually assaulted have various
reasons they don't want to come forward
when they're 12 they may want to come
forward when they're 16 or
17 and the laws accommodating that and
the law is saying we understand that so
the whole idea of statute of limitations
in the law is becoming less and less
favored because it's only its true
effect is to block people from Seeking
Justice and I think at some level the
documentation here I mean one of the
effects of pasas is kidney disease I
know a lot about kidney disease I've had
it since birth and I've had a transplant
so I know the developmental time of
knowing what you have I know I had
kidney disease how serious what it cause
was you know I didn't know but there's
no as the representative just said to me
there's no
harm in saying extend it longer this is
complex matters new information is being
found about causes of diseases that may
be relevant uh and the like
on a harm benefit analysis I just don't
see the the harm outweighing the benefit
of extending it but that's how I see it
representative mcf far thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker keep promoting me
thanks Mr it's it's yeah sorry Mr
chairman nevertheless
um I uh RSA 485hp
um the clock starts ticking at the early
ER of when the plaintiff discovers the
harm or in the exercise of reasonable
diligence should have discovered it I do
believe that stale claims undermine
legal certainty and fairness and I
generally support reasonable statutes
limitations when it comes to pasas
contamination and its long-term health
and environmental impacts we have to
recognize the critical difference
between when someone should with
reasonable diligence have known that
their exposure could lead to damages and
when they fully grasp the extent of
those damages enough to take action per
floro Aly polyflor alile substances
contamination is a slow moving crisis
and the health effects and environmental
consequences may take decades to
manifest we know that victims may only
realize the full scope of their harm
long after initial exposure making rigid
time limits on the claims unfair and
impracticable uh I would suggest that as
we consider hb1
199 we support ensuring that those
harmed by the exposures have a chance to
seek Justice while also
maintaining that the you know this is
about balancing accountability and
reasonableness and the purposes that we
typically see put forward for statutes
of limitation are not ones here I think
to represent D bur's Point um that
outweigh these harms I would urge my
colleagues here to vote their conscience
on a bipartisan
basis anyone else wish to be heard
seeing none um I'd ask the clerk to call
the role the motion is
OTP
199 Vice chairman Manion
no representative
Alexander representative trip no
representative Andrew
no representative Perez
yes clerk votes no representative
McFarland
yes Representative gzowski
no representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Burch yes representative Paige yes
representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes representative berson
yes and chairman Lynn
passes all right
um representative
Smith yeah uh all right
um and will there be a minority
report somebody wish to write I'll write
one Mr chair oh go ahead representative
cab would you like toite the minority
Umi
majority K you really be happy
all right um so that takes care of 199
um so where are we 115 it will be ready
okay all right all right um so we're g
to pass over to uh 32 for a moment and I
will
um turn to uh House Bill two uh
53 and I would Rec repres recognize
representative Alexander for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I move to retain
hp253 is there a second I second right
so the mag moved by representative
Alexander seconded by representative kab
representative Alexander do you wish to
speak to your motion yeah very briefly I
really like this bill I think this bill
is very important I think it should go I
think it the um IA funds should go to
cases in which the state has a
constitutional obligation to fund and I
think going to the public defender
office would be a great way to do it um
instead of relying on um organizations
that sometimes Lobby for um activities
that I don't necessarily agree with um
I'd rather it go to something that you
know the government has a constitutional
obligation to fund but I think we need
to do some work on it so I'm happy to
hold on to it and uh get it to an a to
pass in the
fall anyone else wish to be we heard
representative uh Horgan um well first
of all the bill is unnecessary the
judicial branch is already doing
something confidence same purposes but I
was a little bit
uh dumbfounded by some comments I call
the sponsor making well he complaining
about npos nonprofit organizations even
call them NGS and that's kind of uh
inconsistent what we've been hearing a
lot how the government isn't supposed to
be doing things we should be relying on
charities now suddenly these Charities
are npos somehow now suddenly they're
nefarious too so it's almost like uh
they don't think anybody should be
helping U you know
the helping the people who are helped by
those organizations so that's kind of a
weird thing especially he singled out uh
well couple one organization I'm very
sympathetic to and like work with a lot
the disability rights centers he's very
upset that they were uh you know
apparently especially was outraged by
the fact that they had sponsored a lot
suit where apparently a handicap
entrance had been blocked for some
period of time so he thought that was
like a really outrageous thing and that
was like I thought I strongly support
that organization um I haven't donated
to disability right I've disabil to
another disability rights I was and also
like he's also complaining about the
Catholic Charities because they were
helping uh you know certain people he
doesn't think should be in the states
those are like just two really
remarkable just a remarkable statements
and you know that you know just I mean
obviously comments people making the
hearings don't necessarily mean the
whole bill is a bad idea but that was
just something I thought was really one
of the OD one of the more interesting
things I've heard in these hearings but
um maybe I didn't need to bring that up
in such detail because also just the
bill is unnecessary anyway because there
already is a mechanism to use those
funds so this is and it's not
even not even clear if uh the pr if the
public see if the public defender office
is even um donating to to Charities
anyway so that's um so all right
representative Smith uh thank you very
much
um
um Mr chairman I was almost going to say
Mr Speaker but I you know um that's just
because I like to follow representative
McFarland's lead um I find this
discussion just
fascinating
um if I for example
were to decide that I wanted to give
money to the Portsmith
Symphony
um uh could the
state say um well no uh we don't like
the music that the Port Smith Symphony
plays and so we think you've got to give
money
to um oh I can't think of something else
I problem but
um and I mention that because this is
not State money we're not talking about
State money we're talking about money
that belongs to private
individuals we're talking about money
where
attorneys have um uh taken some money
from their private clients
and um it is reason we call it Iola is
it's interest um
interest uh uh on lawyers trust accounts
that's what Iola stands for it's private
money and lawyers have this money and
it's usually for a short term it's
nickels and dimes from each lawyer and
another number of years ago in a very
intelligent decision in this state and
in many others Banks
recognized that there was really no
point in having a separate account for
each one of these of these uh of the the
lawyers clients they put the money
together and like anything else you know
a nickel here a nickel there pretty when
you're talking about real money but it
is not State money it is private money
and um the
uh under state
law the state is required to provide
legal counsel in criminal matters for
those who are obliged to go through the
court system um the Supreme
Court um something that I respect and I
certainly know that at least one of us
has actually been part of that um the
Supreme Court passed a rule a
significant number of years ago that
said um that uh they would do what so
many other states have done agree to
have Iola um in this state have that
money pulled and then make it possible
for that money um to be used uh for
public purposes but it's not State money
and everybody recognizes that um if in
fact the
criminal uh the people involved in
criminal
defense um the the public
defenders um run out of money which they
do they have an option they can go to
the fiscal committee and ask for more
money to meet the needs of of those
people who are Income eligible uh for
Public Defense in criminal matters this
is a way to make it possible
for people people who are in civil
courts to get some
benefit um it to usurp the right of the
courts to decide for them for what will
happen with this money um makes
absolutely no sense in terms of um
access to Justice and uh this
bill does not serve the people of the
state well and it does not respect the
separation of powers I know the concept
of separation of powers might be going
out of style but I still believe in the
separation of powers and I believe the
courts have the right to decide what to
do um and therefore I very very strongly
oppose
oose uh this bill and hope that we don't
retain it um because there is nothing
that we could do um to meet our
constitutional obligations if we retain
it and therefore I strongly
oppose um retention as I would strongly
oppose OTP right other anyone else wish
should be heard representative Bur
thank you Mr chair or Mr Speaker the
case may be um I have a little poker
game that I play Friday night Joe's in
it and bunch of friends and we agree
that
um at for each pot we put aside 10% to
uh donate to charity and Joe and I dis
agree sometimes on the Charities but we
do it and we enjoy doing that um I would
be very
forlorn if the New Hampshire legislature
came in and said grabbed our little pot
of charitable money and said uh we
decide we want to use it to to refurbish
the chairs in rep's
Hall and I would say you know that's
nice State of New Hampshire but that's
not your money and to the extent that I
hear from time to time that taxation is
theft you know it seems to me that if
you want a prime example of the state
picking the pockets of private
individuals and their money that this
bill may represent that so I'm on the
fence about voting to retain because I
hear what uh the eminent wisdom of uh
representative Smith so I'll figure that
out in the next few minutes thank you
all right um representative
mcfar thank you Mr chair chman um it's
been a long weekend and I have nothing
Jermaine to say on this except to say
that I wholeheartedly support everything
representative Alexander said but I just
wanted to take the opportunity to say
the word chairman another few times Mr
chairman so thank you thank you all
right uh representative Manos thank you
Mr chair um one of the things we heard
testimony about was um I believe it's
Supreme Court rule 50 which um gives us
the ability to
um petition the Supreme Court or meet
with the rules committee or however it's
done internally I don't know um but to
Advocate there's a process under rule 50
to advocate for what the division of the
the iila money should be and how it
should be allocated and how it should be
spent and so I would urge us to defeat
um the motion to retain I oppose the
bill um because there's a perfectly um
there's a perfectly available method to
address the division of how the iala
money is allocated and spent and I think
that that's the appropriate method for
moving ahead and I don't think that this
is it all right so I would oppose
retention and oppose the bill hang on
hang on represent yes representative
it's been brought to my attention I
referred to representative Alexander as
Joe and uh only because in real life
that's what I call him so I I do tender
my apology for referring to my friend
from across the aisle in that such an
informal manner all right representative
Oregon um yes I wanted to I I commented
earlier on um well Roman numeral 2 in
section two that so there's no we didn't
get information about what nonprofit
organizations the uh public defenders
office is actually uh actually
contributing to although I think he did
cite
three specific organizations whose
activities he objected to at least two
actually all three of which I was kind
of dumbfounded that anybody would find
them objectionable but that's just my
opinion but there's there's no data
about what nonprofits they're
contributing funding to I would not be
surprised to learned there aren't any
and also the public defenders office
certainly I've seen Defenders looking at
campaign Finance finings I've never seen
the public defender office contributing
any political campaign in fact I think
probably would be certainly questionable
if they did so and it be probably be
illegal but there's I definitely know
there's no evidence that the public
defenders office is in fact contributing
to political campaigns um and I can't
imagine I'd be astounded if they were so
um so the problem that's trying to be
solved at least by that subar of the
ball as far as it tell non-existence I'm
not sure what the retained Bill process
might or might not be a good I'm not
sure not sure whether having a retained
Bill process to deal with a problem
that's obviously non almost certainly
non-existent I'm not sure if that's
really a worthwhile use of our time even
though I just earlier today proposed
retain Bill process on another bill so
all right thanks all right anyone else
wish to be heard so I just what the only
comment I would make is I I think that
with respect to the respectfully with
respect to both representative Smith's
comments and representative burch's
comments the the the problem here I
agree completely that this money is
private money it belongs to the clients
and what happens now under Iola is the
Supreme Court directs clients don't get
a choice the money goes into these trust
accounts and it goes where the Supreme
Court says it's okay for it to go um I I
disagree with the with this bill in the
sense that it would say basically it
would say instead of the Supreme Court
appropriating the money to its fa
favored places we will appropriate it to
our favored places either the the the uh
public defender or the general fund what
really ought to happen is there this
money ought to go back to the clients
and I went and looked briefly I I looked
uh went back to the there there are two
supreme US Supreme Court cases on this
the first one held that there was that
that what was done here was a taking and
then there was a later case that said
well no it's it can be for a public
purpose both of those were five to four
decisions I have very little doubt that
if this issue got to the Supreme Court
today they the the decision that upheld
this as not being a taking would be
reversed I feel very strongly about that
because one of the big one of the big
arguments that was made back then 30
years ago whatever was F there were two
arguments made in support of this first
that the money was generally small each
client was a very small amount of money
number one but number two that um it was
difficult to to decide to determine at
that time how much money was actually
due to each client and so that was the
other rationale for why well it's going
to be really hard to figure this out I I
suspect and that's why I think retention
is a good idea so we can find this out I
suspect that with today
technology that would not be a hurdle at
all that that Banks could very easily uh
come up with a system that would say
Okay client a had the had you know
$10,000 in this account for 12 days
uh whatever uh and here's the amount of
Interest so I think that that it would
be very easy to determine what that is
and I think what if if we find out in
through through the retention process
that that is in fact the case
then I think it would be appropriate to
say this money belongs to the client the
um it it it doesn't go to it doesn't go
to the court it doesn't go to the bar
Foundation it goes back to the client
and if it's only uh you know and if the
client I suppose if the clients wanted
to execute wanted to consent to have the
money go to the bar Foundation great
that's that's that's that's their
decision but it shouldn't be that that
it's just appropriated in the way it's
appropriated now so for those reasons I
support the retention and I hope we'll
find out what the real situation is um
anyone else wish to be heard seeing none
i' would ask the uh clerk to call the
retain Vice chairman Manion
yes representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab
yes representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative gzowski
Smith representative Horgan
no representative Burch yes
representative Paige
yes representative Manos
no representative tur
yes representative Rambo
yes representative berson
yes chairman Lynn uh
yes 16 Ys two Nays
to Mr chair I'd like to explain my vote
Yes of course
um I very strongly oppose this bill um
but
um one of the things I can do is count
and as soon as it was clear to me that
there would be enough votes to retain um
and that anything else would not be in
the majority um I voted to retain
because if there is a way to use this as
a vehicle to improve the way we meet the
needs of indigen clients um who
um are involved in civil or criminal
matters then I want to be part of that
process all right all right um so uh
16-2 um uh can this go on consent or it
doesn't go on it's retained oh I'm sorry
it's retained that's no I'm sorry you're
right you're right and no report report
okay no sorry about that all right all
right
so um all right
um we've done that let's retain um all
right uh let me turn to
um House Bill uh
um which is uh
dealing with uh the board of tax and
land appeals
um and I would recognize um
representative Manos uh for I I
understand has an amendment and a motion
I do have an amendment you're um Mr
chair excuse
me I do have an I'm getting all these
promotions did you say Mr chief justice
no um I circulated
did I we have to first move
OTP a I'd like to move otpa I'd like to
move my Amendment 0539
h i all right so hang on one second um
y oh okay I will apparently I did not
distribute them so I will pass them
out well you sent us out in you sent us
okay
um all right so do you want to speak to
your uh Amendment yes yes thank you Mr
chair so my amendment is very simple um
we heard testimony this is about land
and tax appeals um and the concern is
that the statute as it currently is
written provides that um here ings will
be held in the county where the land is
located and um the board is not able to
frequently not always but frequently is
not able to find space in the uh
relevant County so this uh Amendment
would simply say that the hearings would
continue to be in the county um unless
um there isn't unless the board
determines that there isn't space in the
county isn't available space in the
county
and then it would be held at the board's
hearing room and conquered so um I think
it's pretty straightforward
Amendment and I would ask for the
committee to adopt it and then pass otpa
right anyone else wish to be heard on
this I have to say I think it's a good
amendment I think it makes a lot of
sense and it cover it captures the
things you were concerned about um all
right anyone else wish to be anyone else
wish to be
heard uh yes represent Perez
seconded um all right so I think we're
um are you well let me ask you first on
the on the on the uh Amendment it seems
like it's probably not controversial can
I ask uh for a show of hands all those
in favor of amendment
20253 59h please raise your
hand
0359 I'm sorry 0359 H right uh raise
your hand anyone anyone
opposed all right so that's um
18 17 oh okay hang on
um
17 all right
um Amendment
17 17 oh all right then we're now on to
uh there were two out two out okay was
out too I'm sorry bir so it's 16 to0 all
right so now we're back to the main MO
motion U again I recognize
representative Manos do you move otpa I
um all right um any any further
discussion on the on the
bill all right so then I'd ask the clerk
to call the role this is on the main
motion of
otpa on House Bill 268 with
Amendment uh 20253 59h representative
Manion yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland
yes representative guzowski yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horan yes representative Burch yes
representative Paige yes representative
Manos yes representative tur yes
representative rmo yes I can't call on
um no then representative representative
Lynn and rep chairman Lynn
yes 17 Ys zero Nays all right
consent can this go on anybody object to
going on consent all right consent and
honors right all right
representative Bon wasn't here all right
[Music]
right no not yet that's what we're
um right I'm going to I'm going to take
up next um House Bill
293 FN and I will recognize uh
representative kutab for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move to
retain House Bill 293 is there a second
I'll second that seconded by mooved by
representative gab second by
representative uh pel um representative
kab you wish to speak to your motion
very briefly I think that this is a
really important bill for protecting
kiddos from this I think Parents try
their best
but with technology it can really
difficult and I think if we can kind of
clear up some of the language on this it
it could be a really good bill all right
anyone else wish to yes representative
pet yes thank you we've gone back and
forth quite a bit even within our own
caucus about this bill and I just want
to draw attention to the fact that um a
very small organization managed to
accumulate 174 signatures um in a very
short amount of time I think it was from
4:00 the afternoon before hearing to
when we had the hearing and I think that
just demonstrates how important this is
to parents and families that we do
something to try to protect their
children from um pornography and
obscenity that they have access to
online right anyone else wish to be
heard only oh I'm sorry representative
bur just to say briefly if we do retain
I hope we pay some attention to the
concern that the New Hampshire library
trustees Association brought up about
how this would impact uh the ability of
libraries that hand out tablets to uh
adults and children coming in and what
they would have to do to change their
technology and whe they can afford to do
so in the like I just hope that's paid
attention to yes representative kab um I
would be honored to chair this committee
if you're willing to have me and I would
love to have you on the subcommittee rep
Birch to kind of to to address that that
concern I think that's something that we
could definitely find a way to address
all right so uh the suggestion is to
form a subcommittee um representative
some oh no no no I right I no I
understand I'm just U um all right um so
on the question of of the the motion to
retain anyone else wish to be heard on
that
well
justes yes I'm just I'm just a little
confused when it says the bill requires
manufacturers of electronic tablets to
me that
sounds interesting like that could be
difficult when we order laptops like I'm
on the board of a school district and
that's what we do we give our students
that or and their families could I just
ask you get a little closer to the my
I'm having trouble hearing you
representative iot it was over here so
at this point um I'm not I'm I'm very
confused by the first sentence is what
I'm saying because the manufacturer
like what's that just the manufacturer
of my laptop like Lenovo or and I asked
and then we asked them to do it before
that's that's the idea yeah just to
require manufacturers to have to have
those things representative H um I just
want to point out that it's uh strictly
strictly limited to filtering out uh
sexual material so there's nothing in
there about uh gu nothing in there about
uh violence nothing in there about hate
speech nothing against a number of other
subject areas that like uh parents may
have qualms about experiencing their
children too so strictly you know it's
about nothing but uh it's about nothing
but sexual materials it doesn't it um
doesn't cover the full gamut of a
potentially objectionable material that
uh you might want to protect your
children from but um
all right anyone else um wish yes
representative I guess I'm looking at
this to prevent minors from accessing
obscene material are we supposed to
Define
that the it's the definition of obscene
I think is in the
bill um Mr chairman I if um a member of
this committee has concerns about the
language of the bill might it be
appropriate then to vote to retain the
bill no that's I think that's that's no
I think that's exactly right I I I think
I should say um um I I speaking
personally I am
personally inclined to support something
like this bill I I had uh two concerns
one is I I I did have a concern about
the private cause of action and
particularly the private cause of action
part that set a 50 ,000 uh civil penalty
basically I'm I am concerned about that
um but you know if if everything else
was was okay I might be able to get over
that but the other thing that I'm
concerned about I would say candidly um
from a discussion the people on my side
of the aisle had last evening and in
particular rep comments that were made
by uh um representative McFarland
who appears to have a fair amount of
knowledge in this area um that seemed to
gel with some with a call I got from a
lobbyist representing the IND industry
suggesting that um there's there is
there are some real concerns about the
details of how this would actually work
and so given that um I think it does
make sense to retain this so that we can
I mean my view would be so that we can
have a a sub committee look at this and
come back with um a proposal with May
perhaps suggested changes or whatever
that would make um that would make us
all more comfortable to be able or at
least all of us hopefully all of us but
at least all of us on my side of the
aisle be more comfortable with voting
for this um so for that reason I think
the retain is a is a good idea and I
intend to support it um anything anyone
anyone else have any comments all right
seeing none then I would the motion is
uh to retain House Bill
293 and um I would ask the clerk to
please call the role Vice chairman
Manion
yes representative Alexander
yes representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
cutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland
yes representative gzowski
yes representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Burch yes representative Paige yes
representative Manos
yes representative tur yes
representative Rambo yes representative
berson yes and chairman Lynn yes 18 y
zero
Nays okay all right um you know what I'd
like to do is uh call a brief recess
do
that
e
the
it does it does have the boiler plate
the I'm going to call the Judiciary
Committee back to uh order um for um the
last bill we have to exact today that is
uh House Bill 232 FN and I recognize uh
representative peternell for um a
motion thank you Mr chairman I would
like to move ought to pass on House Bill
232 and adopt move to adopt Amendment
all right is there a
second all right hang on
um all right so hang
on
okay um uh representative pel do you
wish to speak to your um uh motion yes
thank you I'll speak to both the bill
and the amendment so well it's it's kind
of all the same it doesn't really it
doesn't really it still has the same
purpose the same statement of intent um
it provides that healthc care providers
have a right to conscientiously object
in providing abortion or sterilization
procedures the amendment
removes um the part about
conscientiously objecting to artificial
um birth control um the bill requires
Healthcare institutions to prominently
post an employee notice establishes
civil remedies including
fines um so what this amendment does um
it actually updates the definition of
abortion because that wasn't consistent
with um what's current law in RSA
32943 um because it was calling an
ectopic the original the bill itself not
the amendment was referring to an
ectopic pregnancy um removing an ectopic
pregnancy as an abortion which is not um
so then
anywhere that it reference so let's see
line 17 through 19 from the original
bill was removed because that's
artificial contraception or
contraception and then sorry
um in line
26 of the on page two of the original
bill it removes or the prescription or
provision of artificial
contraception uh line 28 it removes or
the prescription or provision of
artificial
contraception
sorry
section four is
added after line 35 on page two which
was the amendment that representative
Pearson brought in which says that this
section shall not apply to a health care
provider employed by a healthc care
institution that provides abortion or
sterilization Services as a major part
of its services
nor shall this section apply to a health
care provider who is the only health
care provider present in an emergency
situation so there was concern that
maybe somebody might want to go work at
a facility that only performs that's
primarily performs abortions and wanted
to exercise their right of conscience
and that would be against the purposes
of that type of a
facility um other than that the bill is
fundamentally the same and
if yeah all right anyone else wish to be
heard on uh the amendment uh to HB uh
FN yes representative far I only need to
ask Mr chairman I I was under the
impression that this amendment was going
to um
remove the uh paragraph about artificial
contraception or
contraception um and make a couple of
others minor changes but it seems to
have changed other elements of the
language as well for example abortion
has been
redefined I mentioned that at the
beginning yes it did it the definition
of abort abortion has been changed to be
consistent with 329 colon 43 which is
our fetal Life protection
act are there any other comments oh yes
representative Rambo thank you I also
had a note that I had understood an
amendment was going to address the
concern about uh a receptionist for
instance be able to turn somebody away
without without um explanation for
appointment or providing referral but to
be clear since we just got this that
provision has not been amended or
included I didn't remember that being
brought up specifically okay that thank
you any other anyone else um have any
question about the amendment all right
um I I I throw it out uh I I'm prepared
to have a vote on the amendment by a
show of hands unless somebody wants a
roll call and if they do I will call I
will have a roll
call all right so on the amendment that
seeing no no objection on the amendment
13 14 all right all those opposed please
raise your
hand
two four all right 14 to four all right
um
four passes all
right all right so we're now on to the
main uh bill and the chair again
recognized representative pel do you
have a motion as to otpa on the m bill
with the amendment yes thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass with as
amended and is there a
second all right um so move by
representative
peternell
Perez all right um anybody have any
other uh anybody want to make any
further statements with regard to the
main motion of ought to pass as aend yes
representative oh I'm sorry
representative RBA going to defer to
representative Manos first oh all
right thank you Mr chair I I strongly
strongly strongly oppose this bill um we
all recognize the right of um religious
freedom uh both under our Federal
Constitution and our state constitution
and we all respect that however this
bill um
deny services to people who have other
religious points of view there is no
balance between um the services that can
be denied and there's no liability uh
protecting there's no patient protection
um most critically this bill could lead
to delayed or substandard medical care
throughout New Hampshire um and it can
result in harm or death to patients
the other thing that I think is
critically important is that in rural
areas um where there are few
providers patients can be left without
any care particularly in Risky and
dangerous
situations there's no provision for
employees giving notice of their um
exercise of their rights to conscience
so that patients don't know that they're
um dealing with somebody with a medical
provider who is exercising that right um
there's no exception for emergency
medical care which is
critical
um and then although there is an
amendment to exclude um to exclude um uh
birth control
um even that is not sufficient in my
point from my point of view um
sterilization is still
included
um the other thing that I think is is
very problematic about this bill is that
it precludes health care providers
from um making any adjustments in their
Staffing to um provide services that it
is it would be viewed as discrimination
for an employer to reassign people to
different shifts or different job titles
um and so that impacts again impacts
patient care
um and um those are my major concerns
about this bill I strongly oppose it all
right anyone else wish to be heard um
I'm sorry somebody over yes
representative Rambo I think you were
next thank you um I think representative
Manis was pretty comprehensive uh I just
want to reiterate what I raised during
the amendment discussion with which is
that under the bill we have a scenario
where a patient could come seeking
Medical Care receptionist could deny
that care or an appointment does not
need to tell any medical provider at the
facility does not need to provide a
referral does not need to provide an
explanation that strikes me as an
extremely dangerous situation to be
putting patients in so I I appreciate
the efforts with the amendment um but it
does
not it it does not change the underlying
okay all right uh yes representative
Perez So to that point um respectfully
representative maners Catholic Hospitals
don't put a big sign out front saying we
don't do
abortions um and they there's a lot of
things that Catholic Hospitals do not do
but they don't go and advertise that and
if someone comes walking in the door
they don't don't say to them oh by the
way we don't give our birth control or
do abortions or tie your tubes
um so are you do you feel that our our
uh religious hospitals are providing are
discriminating against in the same way
that some a bill like this would be I'm
not trying to be argumentative no I I
appreciate your question may I may I
respond to of course yes
um I think the difference is that
Catholic Hospitals
um exercise their right to not provide
certain services but patients know that
and so in the first instance in a
non-emergency
situation um depending on the on the
patient point of view they wouldn't go
to a Catholic Hospital but under this
bill um somebody in a a a health care
provider at a Catholic Hospital wouldn't
be able to even say we cannot provide
that service but here are three other
places where you might go to receive
that service and that is very
problematic and particularly if if a
patient goes into a uh Catholic
Hospital and an emergency is either
developing or develops after they're
there and they need emergency treatment
to then not be referred to another
provider is is extremely can lead to
severe injury or death Catholic
Hospitals in an emergent situation
having worked in mostly Catholic
Hospitals by chance in an emergent
situation they do provide any medical
care that is required and I have been in
multip you s in your micone yeah can
yeah please I have been in multiple
situations working in a Catholic
Hospital where things that they know
do are done because of an emergent
situation but to your point that people
know Catholic Hospitals don't do that I
don't I don't agree with that I I I
think we are such a diverse uh Community
now and society that I do not believe
all people know that when they walk into
a Catholic Hospital that they won't be
able to get their tubes tied if they
wanted to so you know um I just disagree
with that so again if I could I don't
want to end up with a debate here so
representative Oregon you had something
you want to
say well I'm I'm oppos opposes this bill
but um even it's a good idea that it
only covers uh one particular set of
medical procedures um which one at least
certain religious groups object je to so
there's like a number of other uh
medical procedures with various other
religious groups mostly much less
powerful and much less uh numerous in
the Catholic church are opposed to but
there's no if we're going to have right
to freedom of conscious for medical
professionals which are probably you
know would probably be more consistent
to expand it you know to include U other
things that other religious groups
object to but I I feel like uh but my
main objection bill is just that um the
decision to pursue a medical career is a
voluntary one so you know you don't
necessar nobody's nobody's forced
against their will to pursue a medical
career and then also your choice of
where to be employed is also voluntary
one so if you don't want to be involved
in um don't want to be involved in
abortions or like ifess we took
artificial contraception out or these
other things you are free to seek out an
employer which doesn't even provide
those services and then this issue is
not going to come up at all so I think
that's uh probably would just leave it
up to the individuals to decide whether
or not a particular career meets their
ethical standards and then then also
within the career whether the particular
employer that they pick um meets your
ethical standards and um so I think you
know individuals can make individuals uh
can make their own choice about what
careers to pursue and where where to
where to work so I don't I think I don't
think this bill is needed at all so all
right anyone uh let's see so
representative pel and then
representative tur and then
represent uh bur thank you I just want
to address a couple of the concerns that
have come up one on the amendment at the
bottom of page two line 36 it says nor
shall this section apply to a health
care provider who is the only health
care provider present in an emergency
situation so that would take care of
rural Health Care where the physician or
any provider might
be making the sole determination of the
outcome for the of the patient care and
then I also want to point to um
testimony from New Hampshire right to
life where they stated um gave testimony
about a case at University of May oh
sorry University of Vermont Medical
Center and a nurse
was um assigned to scrub into I believe
scrub into an abortion procedure and she
had been on a list of
objectors and unfortunately she um felt
that she couldn't say no in that
situation even though there were other
providers um available and she's been
traumatized and then um the case was
kind of left to go to the Wayside when
Federal Administration changed so that's
to me is an example of why we need this
in New
Hampshire representative tur yeah thank
you um there's a couple of reasons why I
think this is uh somewhat of of a danger
Bill and it sort of Builds on what
representative Rambo said and also a
little bit about what representative
Perez brought up
um in this bill objecting is something
you do in your head there's no process
for objecting
and the way the bill is
structured that means patients will not
know if their care is being directed by
the choice that someone's making in
their head or the available or the
organization's policies and getting sort
hospitals fundamentally what this bill
is about is your ability to make a care
Choice other than the policy of the
organization that you're employed for so
it really doesn't pertain to a Catholic
Hospital that has a policy against
providing abortion it basically says you
as an individual might have a moral
objection to something that your your
employed provider organization thinks uh
would be their policy and you can just
basically in your head object to it it
also says if that employer finds out
that you made the moral
objection that you can't be fired you
have to be reinstated to your job your
actual job so if we found out that the
receptionist is not allowing people to
into into the clinic and and you said
anything about it as an employer you'd
be forced to reinstate that person as a
receptionist and continue to allow them
to basically disrupt your practice you
can't even reassign them to a a
different job um
and uh sorry I lost my I lost my point
for a minute but it
it's it's opening the door to allowing
sort of anyone to make decisions in
their head and never have to pay the
consequences or never even have to
disclose to their provider and I I'll
one other thought
is as pertains to abortion maybe other
care uh not covered
here the non-provision of those Services
is also something people could object to
and I don't know if that's covered or
not but basically you might say at
Catholic Hospital they say well you
can't provide the care it's possible for
an organization to say and we don't want
you making referrals for that care
because that's the equivalent and here
you could say well I morally object to
that that is the standard of care the
care is legal the care is available I
should be able to refer someone if we're
not going to provide it here so there's
a whole bunch of things in here that I
think if you logically follow what this
is saying puts uh provider organizations
in difficult positions put patients in
the position of not really understanding
what their their standing is so thank
bur and the way I like to do some of
these things is to take a few steps back
and look at the larger
implications of legislation like this so
I'm not going to talk specifically about
the good parts or bad parts of this
legislation because I think it's been
covered but what we're doing here as a
state what we're doing here is carving
out something in my opinion from the
anti-discrimination laws of our state so
let's we have a definition of
conscientious objection object because
of religious belief or moral or ethic
conviction and I'm wondering what ha
what the difference is between somebody
who says I don't want to serve a black
person because of my I have a moral or
ethical conviction I don't want to serve
a Jewish person because of my moral or
ethical convictions I don't want to rent
my home uh to I don't want to sell a
cake uh a wedding cake to a gay couple
uh because of my moral and ethical
convictions so what are we really doing
here we're carving out out of our
anti-discrimination laws and saying well
this one is has to do with abortion but
what's the next bill and the next bill
and the next bill have to say about we
don't don't have to treat people uh if
we're open for
business uh to the public we hold
ourselves open to the business public we
accept the benefits of whether it's tax
or or um corporate status or whatever or
nonprofit status but we don't want to
hold ourselves open to everyone and I
think that runs contrary to the whole
history of our anti-discrimination laws
and that I think is worth thinking about
thank you anyone else wish to be heard
so I guess I would uh say that I I
support this
because I think the issues that you
raise uh representative Burch um those
those are the issues you know about uh
the the cake as an example I mean those
those issues have been before The
Supreme Court now a few times and I
think that the Supreme what the Supreme
Court has said on the constitutional
basis is that the the religious um the
the religious uh Freedom aspects First
Amendment freedom of religion aspects of
U of A person's belief are something
that are entitled to protection and so
what I would say is you say carve out uh
from the civil rights laws I would say
that this is actually adding to the
Civil in other words it is saying that
you can't just like you can't
discriminate on the basis of race or sex
or whatever the other categories are you
can't discriminate against someone on
the basis of their religious beliefs if
they if someone has um a a religious
belief that says they don't want to do
certain things that's entitled to
protection um I I think that's so I I
think I guess I think that this operates
exactly the opposite of the way you uh
you describe it and I think there are
the uh you know one of the things that I
was very concerned about I that's I
raised this first rais this issue with
representative Pearson is I was saying
well the original bill that as it was
worded if if some if some for example
pro-life group I suppose wanted to try
to you know upend the operations of
Planned Parenthood would they be able to
have you know for lack of a better term
an undercover a bunch of undercovered
doctors go in take accept employment
with Planned Parenthood and then say I
refuse to perform abortions and I'm
covered by I'm entitled to protection
under the statute and representative P
Pearson understood that and that's why
he put in the the change that said if
it's a if a major part of the operate of
a the the business's operation is to
perform abortions um you can't then go
to you know and you know that you you
take a job with Planned Parenthood you
then can't say I'm not going to perform
abortions but if it's not that if it's
just you know the hospital performs a
whole bunch of different things and
abortion might be something that's done
um occasionally then then the the
person's right to to exercise their
freedom of conscience should should
apply I think that I think that makes
sense I I would just go back to the um
cases not the cake cases but the cases
that talk about um uh public
accommodations they make make a
distinction between public
accommodations and private if you are
going to be a public accommodation you
can't have a sign that says no blacks uh
because um uh that kind of
discrimination has not been accepted so
why not have that kind of concept for
your hospital if you want to have a
private hospital and run it the way you
want to and get no benefits from being a
public institution fine have ADD it
but if you're a public institution and
getting all the benefits of being a
public institution then be like a public
accommodation and say anybody walks in
the door that wants our services you
know is entitled to our services now if
those Services aren't there that's
something else that's just my point okay
all right representative man the problem
is patients won't know and can't know
whether they're getting safe reliable
and accurate information and that is one
of the major problems with this
bill all right any other representative
CH yeah I just I just wanted to point
out um sort of building on some of
what's being said um page on the amended
version page two line 11 section five it
still says a healthc care provider means
any individual who as part of her his or
her employment may be asked to
participate in in any way in an abortion
or
sterilization but not limited to a
physician physician's assistant nurse
nurses aid medical assistant hospital or
clinic employee pharmacist Pharmacy
employee medical school student Medical
School employee or any professional
paraprofessional or other person who
furnishes to assist Furnishing an
abortion or sterilization this is way
more than telling a doctor that they
have the right to consciously
conscientiously object to a performing
of an abortion this basically means
anyone in any organization who can
reasonably claim that they are somehow
possibly connected to an abortion or a
sterilization which again we took out
contraception but sterilization is a
form of
contraception um I think makes this
really open-ended and dangerous I hope
people consider that all right anyone
else have anything they want to say
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair I know I know I communicated with
my colleagues that I was thinking about
voting for this but I really after
thinking about it I really don't think I
can support this bill as written um I'm
concerned about um unintended
consequences of enacting something like
this um especially you know being being
a homosexual what the what the
implications of not prescribing like you
know HIV prevention drugs or something
like that if they if it wasn't if it
if somebody objected to a lifestyle that
somebody else has I guess I'm I'm really
really conflicted on this and I just
want my colleagues to know I I think I'm
gonna vote no on that all right anyone
else all right so I um the motion is um
Ro Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander no
representative trip yes representative
Andress yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland yes
representative Gaz offski
yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative bur no representative
Paige
no representative Manos no
representative tur no representative
Rambo
no Representative buron
yes nine Ys nine
Nays right so the motion um of otpa as
uh it fails is there another motion Mr
retain sure is there a second for
alander
second uh representative Alexander do
you wish to speak to your motion no all
right anyone else wish to be heard on
the motion to
retain all right so I'd ask the clerk
then to call the role on the motion to
Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative gzowski yes
representative Smith no representative
Horgan no representative Burch no
representative Paige no representative
Manos
no representative tur no representative
yes and chairman Lynn
days all right
um all right of report for today you
know I I think we're done I guess what I
I was I was gonna suggest we talk about
this letter I got from chman wer but
we've been going too long so I'm just
gonna we'll deal with that um yeah
either Wednesday or next week so you
know what just just for everybody's um
information so we're so Wednesday we
have hearings we start at nine o'clock
we won't be executing anything Wednesday
the next executive session which it it I
think it's been posted but for somehow
some reason it didn't get in the in the
calendar this week the next executive
session will be a week from today on the
10th starting at 1:00 and the reason
it's starting at 1 is I have an Ethics
Committee meeting at 10:
so I and that's going to take a while
because we got a bunch of stuff to do so
we'll start at 1:00 to exec um the the
um a bunch of bills and then um then our
last sort of pre crossover meeting will
be the following Wednesday on the 12th
where we have two bills in the morning
starting at 9:30 to here and then we'll
start our executive session at 11:00 to
finish up the rest of the bills we have
to uh exact and I think that should be
the end of it so thank you all I'm sorry
we didn't have lunch but thank you all
for hanging in there I appreciate it um
all
right